[Musique]
françois lombard mary chez nous c'est
lui merci beaucoup d'avoir accepté de
venir sur le podcast je pense que c'est
l'entrepreneuriat qui ne se fera qu on
n'a pas exploré encore plus je pense que
beaucoup de monde qui sont intéressés
par ce service mais tu décris toi-même
comme un entrepreneur en série
oui sur ton compte instagram fait ce
qu'on pensait qui serait une chose
intéressante à faire c'est de francs en
espèces deux parcours chronologique
oui de ton de ton histoire de ton par go
parce que souvent si j'imagine beaucoup
de hauts beaucoup de bas beaucoup
d'embûches beaucoup de travail
puis je pense que c'est intéressant pour
pour tout le monde qui écoute de d'avoir
ce chemin le parcours entreprenariale y
est on je sais pas aussi moi j'ai ma
j'ai la réponse je pense mais moi je
pense qu on est entrepreneur et c'est
assez difficile le devenir au look et
parents dans nous cette graine la de
devenir un entrepreneur et moi aussi
longtemps je me souvienne je voulais
entreprenant maintenant entre le vouloir
le désir et la mise en place d ok
parfait je loge tout et je plonge
il ya tout un chemin à faire et ça prend
une bonne idée et la maudite bonne idée
elle vient po1
on pense qu'on leur montre pour les
couilles de plongée cette étape l'eau
qui est la plus difficile elle redémarre
et d'entreprises à faire ou lille
c'est compliqué et difficile c'est
compliqué mais il modifie la plongée se
lancer en affaires c'est l'addition
l'édition la plus difficile qu'on fait
parce qu'on accepte de mettre un pain de
côté et dire je vais voler de mes
propres ailes menacé comme parti de chez
nos jeunes au pana il ne jamais revenir
il ya déjà qu'ils font sur l'équipe a
maintenant deux pays puis qui viennent
dans un autre pays
pierre vaux où ils revoient pas leur
parents mais c'est un peu chaud est de
sauter prétend entrepreneurs et autant
que j'ai voulu light j'ai vraiment
plongé comme entrepreneur alors j'ai 33
ans
donc autant que j'ai toujours voulu que
ça me primé ton jeudi à cinq ans que je
pense est entrepreneur parce que c'est
là que je me souviens
mais mettons ça m'a pris 28 à trouver
une bonne idée ouais et il a la bonne
idée parce après une excellente idée
pourtant ça m'a fait vraiment pas ce
qu'on va révolutionner le monde vont le
trouver ce qui manquait dans le marché
mais ce n'est même pas une bonne idée
dans le fond c'est une bonne idée mais
j'ai fait vingt ans avant de monter
c'est que l'idée que j'ai eu avec
georges mon partenaire là on parle on
parle mais on n'est pas cannes l on est
en septembre mais cette arme de m'élever
la bonne humeur de lemoine à la demi
lune est passé et durant l'été
moi j'avais travaillé à toronto pour une
compagnie plus chaud venant montréal
parce que je suppose être le symop ça
fait 18 mois que j'étais l'eau je veux
revenir à montréal puis mon associé lui
revenait du liban on avait déjà
travaillé ensemble qu'on se ramasse dans
un bureau on dit michael lynton plutôt
ravi pour lui ça ne donne plus de
travail et pour personne points faibles
on s'est mis à la recherche d'une des
puits
la reconnaissance la parole commencé
dans ce temps-là on le dit parfait
légère vous ont pu diffuser leurs oeufs
leur ordinateur pour aller sur le net
vont fuser la voix ils vont parler ils
vont parler pour vale sur la voie ça
c'est syrie aujourd'hui ils vont être et
on pense que ces nouveaux aux dents
longues aux bulls ont pilé alex les
choses ça cammas est de plus en plus
mainstream pas parler beaucoup le mais
on le pensait en l'an 2000 nous on le
fait des projets
un des premiers projets qu'on a faim le
fait que la ville de montréal qui était
lorsque le un fou déneigement lorsque
ton auto était d'aînés se faisait
dépasser dans le bénin je m'en tape
lettre son numéro de plaque cozza quelle
place contre le prix à quelle place
qu'on l'envoyait c'était le 1er mai pour
l'emmener main stream avoir un vol ce
porto passé ce qu'on voulait faire on
s'est rendu compte que les gens étaient
propres et aso dont 1
il se prenait énormément d'argent
médecine moi je me sens sale affaire un
point de seine
ouais j'avais zéro de l'ofppt les gens
pensent que pour se lancer à la face à
prendre l'argent donc ça prend une bonne
idée c'est une bonne idée
pis tu travaille comme il faut l'argent
va suivre éventuellement cependant dans
ce qu ici c'était la folie du défunt
ciocca dans le fond ce qui était saine
dans 99 2000 avec ton père tu sais que
tu écris un plan d'affaires tubes et des
belles projections première année je
vais m'arracher deuxième année je vois
un peu de ventre la troisième année sky
is the limit le ok c'était qu'on parle
exactement ce qu on a fait ça aussi
puis on perd iconia des portes à lille
cécile lecomte vallée puis un pana qu'on
écrivait le plan d'affaires le marché
s'est effondré mais il ya un gros cash
puisse à tout péter
la bulle internet vient d'exploser pour
sera mon sac un boss porte au prince m
et là on a dit bon beh parfait on
abandonne le projet parce que je l'écris
dans mon premier livre c'est quand on a
failli a pas de plan b je promène de
plants aux appelants au volant etc puis
lorsque je parle de plan b dans mes
conférences je fais tout en lien avec la
conjointe c'est comme si b puis le monde
comprenne mieux quand elle explique
comme ça ça même chose en affaires c'est
comme si tu étais plus rezac tacon avec
ta conjointe pilotis dibon parfait je me
trouve une maîtrise donc ces nobles en b
qu'est ce qui arrive
ok ton plan b votre écoute route par
exemple je veux pas être un plan b alors
je veux devenir le plan retenu lui dit
inquiète de poche pour régler mes
problèmes
ça s'en vient puis tombe là haut le
taudis m'écouter jamais la fac moi je
vais tout lâcher fait qu'à la fin
qu'est ce qui arrive quand un plan b tu
parlais de l'autre et personne ne veut
d'un plan b pile
tous les deux se ramasse et un plan b
finalement alors que ça ne prenne un
club c'est la même chose on à faire
lorsque tu un plan b qui te divertir
mais ça ne marche plus de recevoir porto
ne marche plus on le flou chez mais
lorsqu'on se lance en affaires
une des choses qu'on perd pas c'est la
matière grise donc quand même que tu te
lance aujourd'hui dans un nouveau
domaine
ce que tu as appris dans toute ta
carrière tu vas l'avoir encore dans six
mois faites moi j'ai dit bon ben j'ai
été consultant en architecture de
centres d'appels je vois tourner
consultant en architecture de centres
d'appels les hommes d'abel par tous
peuvent se retourner faire ce que je
faisais avant
et mes pompes au moins à place a été
rigoureux quelqu'un mais j'étais
consultant et lorsqu'on veut réussir en
affaires faut être capable de se
multiplier né un consultant ne se
multiplient peau il travaille il se
présente au bureau il fait de l'argent
fait plus d'argent que comme s'y est
employé mais se multiplient pendant tard
est le soir de travailler l'argent leur
en but je prends des vacances l'argent
ne rendent plus et pour réussir
moi je dis aux gens tout le temps faut
facturer quant aux doors notre site
facture candidat c'est là que d'une
recette gagnante parce qu'elle ne dépend
plus de toi et tu en as 18 mo cependant
moi j'avais pris la décision je
retournais pu travailler pour quelqu'un
c'est fini alors j'ai 33 ans donc je
retournais comme consultant puis en
cherchant toujours la future bonne idée
et la future bonne idée c'est après 18
mois je les veines en face depuis les
dix dernières années parce que j'ai très
bien dans le domaine des centres d'appel
puis une opportunité de centres d'appels
puis george et moi on a décidé de
s'ouvrir un centre d'appel puis répondre
à leurs besoins qui avait dans le marché
passé son temps à faire on bosse fait
des rêves faisait mouche pour faire si
je vaux façon mais ce qu'on peut faire
c'est ptet pas ce qui va arriver même
année une opportunité que va se
présenter puis en tant que bons hommes
d'affaires foot saute sur les
opportunités et c'est exactement ce
qu'on a fait on a dit oui pour embaucher
20 employés le mercredi on n'a pas de
centre d'appels on n'a pas de chien dans
nombre de bureaux monde et on va trouver
une solution après 18 h
on a embauché déjà on le fait chez le
client engager des gens avant les bases
la fondation de
que vous vouliez faire n'avait entrepris
ce n'est même pas qui était payée par
l'entremise une autre compagnie que je
vais parce qu'on pensait même pas que ça
pour réussir et on y croyait protection
mais ça a marché
l'embauché d'un employé on a livré la
marchandise il en a demandé 40 la
semaine d'après pour nos montées comme
ça jusqu'à 3000 jusqu'à temps qu'on le
vende huit ans plus tard une copie que
c'est un kwassa comporter au début
puisque c'était exactement accompagne
les cotisé c'est des fois le reste au
centre d'appels on prenait des appels au
début on nous a demandé de faty
télémarketing passé comme souvent comme
ça que tu commencé dans le temps donc on
appelait aux gens pour s'accompagner de
téléphone ce défi d'eau et on les
appelait pour hansen campagne qui
s'appelait winsback donc c'est des gens
qui avaient du prix pays de téléphone
prépayées qui avait pour renouveler leur
entente dont il n'avait pas rempli leurs
cartes
ton rôle et ça plaît pour leur offrir et
10 $ de rabais va exactement à 10 $ de
ce suspect vidéo qui faisait affaire
avec vous exact que vous faisiez que les
appels exactement la pression leur
entrée dans le système
notre campagne bien été j'aurai besoin
de d'avoir des agents en et demande donc
conserver sa clientèle
on les a formés ça a marché il ya
presque deux ans plus tard on ne donne
plus belle on l'a eue vidéotron après on
a eu le soleil parce qu'anna donne j'en
oublie donc apprécié aussi citer une
multitude de nouveaux clients qui se
sont joints à nous la et à quoi est-ce
que tu attribue le succès de tout ça est
ce que c'est vraiment quelque chose de
en termes de moments dans le temps que
c'est arrivé est ce que c'est une
demande que vous remplissiez est ce qui
se passe qui avait pas d'autres
personnes qui disent pourquoi est-ce que
ça le marché de cette façon le saloum
marché pour plusieurs raisons la
première chose c'est que il y avait une
opportunité un fournisseur qui est allé
dire non aux clients et dis-moi tevez
employés je ne peux pas te le faire pour
vendredi
je suis pas équipé j'ai pas de place
mais le client avait besoin d'avoir ces
veillées employés là parce que dans 100
lots en 200 2003 il y avait une grosse
il y avait beaucoup de compétitions
entre l'aller les les fournisseurs de
cellulaires pour annoncer le nombre de
nouveaux abonnés qu'elle va chaque
podium en ce moment on entendre parler
non mais dans ce temps là c'était la
grosse affaire on ne gagne et semblait
l'organisme dont il y avait énormément
de pression et y inclus le fournisseur a
dit non le client se revirer de bord dit
moi ça me fera du cif qui peut le faire
puis nous le dit à l'eau puis après ça
on s'est arrangé ok j'avais jamais gérés
de centre d'appels je ne connaisse un
même pot les boss world qui était qui
était avec ça mais bon tout ça brun et
on a appris rapidement sur l'auto pour
les potasses et a livré des résultats et
après son nom commence à s'organiser un
peu plus comme entreprise comment
conserver ns et maintenant après coup
qu'on a eu cette opportunité là après ça
fout les livrer et après ce qu'on a vu
karaoké ont maintenant notre entreprise
est un centre d'appels ce matin moi
j'appelle mon fournisseur d'internet du
5 août j'ai dans l'aude et des films
toute la fatigue ça marche et ça marche
l'appel peau ça marche pour rappel ne
purent un donc tu te fais dérangé par du
télémarketing dont sam un chat je
faisais partie comme tout le monde ça me
dérangeait mais bon c'est une entreprise
et j'ai pas suivi ma passion - je suis
ma raison il y avait une opportunité
il y avait de l'argent enfin parce qu'on
se lance en affaires
quand même qu'on le fait pour la fois
pour toutes les causes au final c'est
comme des artistes et des artistes qui
m'ont peint des tableaux parce que ça
lui fait triper puis trouvent leur
travail très beau bien d'autres artistes
chinoises et non moi je vais faire ce
que le marché demande pour faire de
l'argent il y en a j'en connais des
artistes qui vont énormément d'argent
j'en connais un drop qui va à new york
c'est un québécois c'est un artiste mais
c'est un homme d'affaires a vendu 1 8 20
dollars qui fixe qui avouent ils n'ont
pas ce que lui dit qu'il ferait de la
pop exactement compromettent un peu le
moins possible en tout envie d'aider
mode people et des demandes
parce que des fois on peut très bien
dire non moi je vais faire ce que ça me
tente pas ce que je dois un artiste peut
jouer un peu mais parce qu'il ya pas
grand différence en donnant d'affaires
un artiste a mené bien besoin pour
répondre aux besoins des clients
il est des fois le besoin tu ne le sais
pas siki seidel fois des chansons cdb
biblique qui apparaissent çà peut pas
aux autres que c'était pour marcher dans
sa mais ont répondu à un besoin qui est
et qui était placé pied d'un groupe qui
sont nés avec une seule chanson qui sont
nés par la suite d'un homme d'affaires
c'est la même chose il y avait une
opportunité qu après ça ce qu'on ne fait
par contre on a dit non vous faire
différent ce serait quand même dix ans
que je travaille dans le domaine des
centres d'appels je voyais ce qui
marchait puisqu'il ne marche pas donc
j'avais plus avec ma tête de consultants
puis mon expérience de vie ok parfait
qu'est ce qu'on va faire maintenant
envoyer mais ce qui marche pas d'un
centre d'appels on voit en vo mais ce
qui marche et une des choses qui est
important puisque on gère des gens ont
déjà des gens qui ne veulent pas
travailler dans un centre d'appels
donc le taux d'absentéisme pied
monstrueux ouais ok ils n'ont qu'à
chaque tyran que j'ai envoyée oui les
gens ne veulent pas traverser mais bélie
viennent parce que c'est leur premier
emploi
ils viennent jouer on a le choix
donc qu'est-ce que tu fais tes écart
août soucier de leur trio environnement
le plus intéressant possible tout en
étant difficile parce que tu réponds
qu'à des plaines considère tendu par un
téléphone des trous quelqu'un qui va se
plaindre pour que le timing est fort
chez pierre fo qui a énormément
d'empathie
quand même temps battre à force d'en
prendre si cet appel à jour par jour aux
auditeurs par jour alors par jour soit
60 appels par jour tarifs chez vous des
fatigues et mais bon on ne dit pas fait
faut leur donner des conditions
meilleures des bureaux plus accueillant
que ce soit propre
le salaire je peux pas faire grand chose
le salaire je suis en impartition ça
veut dire que le client le donne ce
qu'il veut pas offert
ok donc une concurrence mondiale c'est
moi je l'entends j'avais le centre
d'appel si le salaire minimum de monte à
15 dollars moi je mettais 3000 employés
d'art
parce que je voulais puis j'aurai plus
ou moins eu de profitabilité
c'est que la concurrence est sans appel
et mondialement concurrence francophone
vient de la tunisie vient du maroc donc
ses employés là auraient été ses 3000
emplois je comprends que c'est pour 3000
emplois de haute technologie mais ces
trois mille endroits qui font vivre
vivre des genres le marché le titre
d'apple c'est toute la francophonie dans
le fond je faisais tu faisais de
francophones puis de l'agglo famille qui
met donc si on faisait peu importe le
marché on faisait on faisait le français
ou l'anglais
ok maintenant lolo par sita question
c'est qu'est ce qu'on a fait moi j'ai eu
des sautes l'école des stations-service
esso le moment donné dans ma carrière et
dans les stations-service esso à fin de
la journée il faut fermer la journée
suffit les fermes ta gueule tu fermes ta
journée te regarde combien d'oeufs
vendus et son appel de vendu combien de
bouteilles de données sleepy toutes les
tv de tête de t d qui bd des choses très
précises avant ceci à chaque jour j se
fait de l'argent j'ai pas faire d'argent
donc nous on est inculqué cette méthode
l'eau comme un dépanneur dans le fond à
la au centre d'appels d'offres car à
chaque 15 minutes on savait qu'on
faisait de l'argent on en faisait pas on
avait mécanisme de rapports qui nous
permettait de se réajuster
donc quand j'évolue cette entreprise
l'an 2012 mme auger a pas de dette pas
protège fait c'est de l'argent c'est
pour ça que je les vends du les mots ce
que on était capable la montée à 3000
employés alors que la moyenne des
centres d'appels à montréal était de 200
ou 300 donc on était capable de sans
s'endetter
on a mis une structure opérationnelle
qui nous permettait d'éviter de voir en
fait si l'argent est roi en a fait sa
peau mais pourquoi la vendre en bout de
ligne ça va bien en fond pourquoi vendre
une entreprise tout simplement parce que
quelqu'un qui t'offre un prix que et moi
pour moi notre première entreprise on a
tendance à la traiter comme un bébé
aïe c'est mon bébé et puis ce point b
si la traite comme un bébé un bébé on
lui pardonne tous ses défauts on lui
pardonne beaucoup de choses
un entreprise dépôt leurs propres
données d'entreprise c'est le pour être
fiable on peut dire ce qu'on veut une
entreprise profitable garantie des
emplois l'entreprise profitable
satisfait actionnaires donc et il ya
personne qui lance une entreprise à
moscou ap qui n'est pas là pour faire de
l'argent souvent l'actionnaire ça se
peut que ce soit le propriétaire unique
ça arrive aussi
mais si bien que l'entreprise fasse de
l'argent à une entreprise qui fait de
l'argent garantit les emplois qui sont
là une entreprise qui est à risque
financier
non aux coupes des emplois tout
simplement pourquoi la vendent parce que
je les vendeurs 2012
et moi je mettais déjà pré retirer cette
entreprise l'an 2010 j'ai des brûlés
mentalement
un centre d'appels si le journées de la
mer morte où toutes les 15 minutes
ok je réinvente les 15 mètres devant le
but plus rien dit et fait l autisme de
tout est géré par tranche de 15 minutes
d'un taux de roulement et de 300%
c'est dur j'avais plaisir et c'est drôle
parce qu'aujourd'hui mon garçon j'ai
deux garçons de 10 et des quinzaines
d'une jeune imam cela que si tu veut pas
la paix puis c'est ce que je veux c'est
ce que j'ai toujours voulu c'est être
libre
avoir la paix quand même que l'on
travaille fort il ya moyen d'en vanter
d'être tranquille d'esprit et je l'avais
plus j'avais jeté devenu le font eux je
devenais fonctionnaires de mon
entreprise tu es rendu trop gros pour
virer sur les dix ans je n'avais plus
goût melville m'avait plat des fonds
c'est donc c'était mieux que je
m'attends ce que je mette un ou deux vp
supplémentaire que je rentre chez moi
puis on eu un prix qui valait la peine
qu'ils valaient la peine puis excuse
s'arrêter bien de la garder l'entreprise
est encore en pleine croissance
est-ce que j'aurais dû le garder
peut-être mais pour moi c'était je passe
à autre chose j'ai fille depuis le test
art et essai tester puis c'est ta
première vente donc c'est toujours le
fan de cacher dans mes côtés ton futur
et régler la pression tu peux t'amuser à
faire autre chose justement la paix
justement c'est dans ce sens dit j'y
travaille tellement fort pendant
tellement longtemps qu amener tous les
goûts aussi de profiter de votre enfant
de
ce que tu finis par te découvrir oui les
enfants c'est certain pouvoir en vent
venait mais tu finis par te découvrir ce
qu'est ce que j'aime dans vie est ce que
ces deux opérés d'entreprises y en a qui
aiment ça
puis sont relax présente le matin pique
son est très bon je peux dire que
j'étais un très bon opérateur passe mes
centres d'appels ce une question de
chiffres et je mémoire je bandais des
foules les bains on peut faire le ton
mais j'ai une mémoire est un peu un peu
asperger je dirais avec les chiffres
j'ai une mémoire phénoménale pour les
référents dans ma tête puis pour moi
c'est un tableau
il se sera pas des voix je ne mets moi
pour ça sauf que j'avais pas de fonds et
jusque j'aime faire c'est de bâtir des
entreprises donc lorsque je me déclare
entrepreneurs en syrie c'est ce que
j'aime faire je me sois partir
d'entreprises du catch à toutes les fois
je me dis mais pourquoi je refais sont
encore mois souffrent et puis ça va
prendre encore trois ans où les trois
mois mais non se ressent encore parce
que celle von thurn challenge telus et
coût social je le passé j'ai plus fort
il faut que je passe à autre chose
puis qu'est ce que c'était l'autre chose
combien de temps ça a pris dedans times
après la vente jusqu'à un autre idée qui
te fait te lever le matin faire que ce
soit mais la première chose je
l'investis dans les entreprises
je suis pas connu il leur est facile de
dire que j'ai de l'argent mais c'est
quand même pas une entreprise fondée et
j'ai de l'argent ne connaît pas le monde
des bébés des investisseurs donc pas ce
que tu gères beau avoir bâti une grande
entreprise pour connu personne bah non
je veux pas la tv fait que
je trouvais pas ce que je cherchais puis
thème année tu prennes pause durant chez
vous puis je vais présenter quand même
au bureau par principe de pori enfin je
me sentais coupable de rien fait mais
j'avais pas de bus ou du début je me
suis ramassé comme ouais ok j'ai 42 ans
fait quoi maintenant
donc ok je vais aller au gym ya jim
couverts par les chinois comme j'avais
jamais été aux jeunes de ma vie j'en ai
mal au jam à la vente a passé 1h30 au
djembé en grèce
il reste beaucoup avec les armes
guardian bon j'avais des jeunes enfants
mais sont à l'école deux jours fait que
j'ai dit ok ils sont avec moi ou jusqu'à
donc je dois trouver quelque chose qui
va me tenir occupé jusqu'à tacler 21 ans
pour apprécier parce que le monde droite
pourraient voyager réponse est oui moi
je n'ai pas d'enfant je peux partir
demain matin pendant un mois deux mois
parvenez puis rendre ici pour partir et
je peux faire ça financièrement ce n'est
pas un problème mais j'ai des enfants
mais j'ai des enfants j'ai des ans a fui
je veux être là avec eux donc je peux
pas les laisser les mets deux hommes
habitent à temps plein avec moi donc
j'ai eu 17 et quinson sont soit en
plaques - depuis un deux puis quatre à
flot depuis deux ans donc j'ai pas de
jets moins de liberté que
que quelqu'un donc c'est parfait ça
prend des projets sinon je peux pas me
lever le matin - pu rien faire
après ça j'ai bon ok qu'est ce qu'on
fait comme entreprises les gens
m'approchent ok c'était une bonne idée
non c'est pas une bonne idée
quinze mille pièces lors la procédure
qui est bonne idée
ok je vais perdre 400 milles fait
l'allemagne étudient le prêt seulement
tu t'approches puis on raisonne
commences à te présenter des 10 watts
par un autre 100 mille l'offre viager
facteurs non l'investir en plus dans les
entreprises comme ça je vois les partis
moi même je contrôlais pas contrôler ça
me tente plus d'être opérationnel mais
je vois mon mot à dire si rien sur le
déroulement comme ça aussi c'est simple
si je me casse la gueule mais je me
casse la gueule ou incomplets la
dernière idée que j'ai faits puis avec
des partenaires ça s'appelle bousmid
donc c'est l'assistance routière est
encore là j'étais petit c'est un peu
drôle un peu parce que j'étais dans une
réunion pas une réunion j'étais en
vacances en floride chez ma blonde hutin
et michael c c'est le cousin de valérie
donc été ma blonde du temps on est
toutes dans maison du grand pas qui est
une grande maison puis sa mère de
michael me dit michael morse a de parler
d'un projet on est dans ta de paul klee
on est en famille en floride
je me dis c'est pas vrai ici c'est le
monde même à pau mashaal mais tout le
monde me sollicitent pour des projets
avec l'âge j'ai fait comme d'annoncer ce
polar principe enflure et pas dans cette
famille l'oeil ont pas besoin d'argent
là pourquoi que îles marshall blonde on
marche un terrain de golf sur le club
house là le dimanche de pâques la
macreuse voici moins bien présente les
deux bouts smip nos cheveux comme
celui-ci la mèche mais je me lève le
matin j'avais ma course je garde je
baisse mon clip
centerpoint au mois d'avril montrent
l'équipe si je monte une équipe
j'embarque m'appelle au début septembre
mais françois g l'équipe au complet j'ai
les bras gamin j'ai sort j'aime partner
georges ma job bon cela j'ai fait comme
ok
mais c'est le fun on est rendu à 3 1
c'est pas d'entreprises encore rentable
mais on est on est sur une très très
belle si on est des baux partenaires
j'avais honte d'aller en norvège voir un
potentiel légaux sur dalle en france
dernièrement voir un potentiel qui
aujourd'hui c'est confirmé je suis pour
ça que je jetais devrait pas tarder car
les gens s'affolent et qu'ils écoutent
mais bon j'étais partant parce qu'on
avait justement cette confirmation la
dont tu le vois que ça pourrait après
trois ans kelly bonne nouvelle en barque
parce que les gens commencent à 0 qu'est
ça fait trois ans que tu existes in line
kobe ça fait trois mois qu'il existe des
faits comme os qui vont peut-être
débarquer
mais après trois ans qu'on est établi
dans le marché le les gens commencent à
nous croire et ça commence à débloquer
donc ça commençait de l'iphone est ce
que ça va être plus gros que le centre
d'appels je sais pas puisque l'important
c'est moi honnêtement je travaille
toujours pour l'argent mais je travaille
à pied en même temps je trouvais pas
pour l'argent
j'en ai assez et si j'en voulais plus je
pourrais travailler jusqu'à 100 les 10
ans d'un stop parce que quand je parle
de mon fils tu en veux me demandez moi
je me souhaite matin melville pitt
presque paoua d'horaire le dit ok
parfait bons jeunes compagnies d'acier à
saint-jérôme si aujourd'hui je vais
aller là bas j'ai dit en garde
aujourd'hui je te lis chibout soumis la
semaine passée en compagnie de max et l
on dise donc je les rencontre et donc je
me sauve plus ou moins gérer ma journée
au jour le jour ce pas toujours possible
le rhin surtout que là on est homo
autour mois de septembre en ce moment
c'est la saison des conférences qui
commence
je regarde mon arrêt des prochains mois
plus au lancement du livre je sais très
bien que ce que je veux comme p le jeune
ce jeu les repas mais c'est le fun parce
que c'est le fun c'est le jeune beaucoup
de conférences mon poste et qu'une
baboune il contestait devant ses fans se
donne en spectacle
puis tu motive les gens sinon suffit
c'était pas capable de le faire pour
motiver les gens puissent voir les gens
s'en foutent un peu de ce que tu dis moi
je le ferai pas je le fais parce que je
le vois que les gens prennent des notes
les gens disent ah ok tu fais ça comme
ça puis tu raconte une histoire salle
tant mieux ça respire les gens puis si
je peux le les aider à ce n'est qu'au
final derrière pour que se lancent en
affaires le vent se lève qui prennent
conscience de cela en avant ben moi j'ai
fait ma job puis j'ai du fun à faire ça
parce que
je me dis tout le temps que puis dans
mes conférences j'ai pas de papiers j'ai
pas ce live ce pôle a pour donner un
cours je le parlais de mon véhicule je
n'allais avec les gens ben c'est sûr que
tu t'en donne peut-être 50 à 100 par
année fait que manu tu finis par
développé l'habitude mais moi je m'en
vais parle aux gens me demandent de
prendre une heure une heure et demie
après la dépasser à havre-saint-pierre
me demandées par les six heures qui fait
que mes coaches jean barral et que 3h30
l'après-midi deux heures et demie soit
je passais bourré mais il ya là des
sujets d'entrepreneuriat qu'on peut
parler puis si je me dis tout le temps y
avait-il des fois c'est des super
bénéfices
puis les jambes ont ils pour les jeunes
entrepreneurs quelques pas et m'évite a
donné une conférence mais les gens se
déplacent une soirée 152 ça des fois 350
personnes proulx venez écouter qu'une
seule personne moi manger puis résultats
en même temps je me disais pee ont payé
ma tension avec un espace assez revient
pas de témoin là une personne et 15
passes on éteint mercredi soir il y
aurait pu les voir un chanteur qui
s'arrête et coûter moins cher
il n'y aurait pas les voir un humoriste
sari coûter moins cher ils viennent ici
faut que je donne un spectacle dont
cannes est ma bouche sérieux quand je
donne des conférences je m'amuse je veux
qu'ils se trouvent ça drôle
je veux kiki qui sont inspirés qui parle
de la beauté
mais j'ai appris quelque chose pour ne
lui plaisait donc c'est ça qui le mon
mandat dans les conférences c'est que je
connais dit von brunn maurice jeu
capable plus une coupe de mais pour
qu'on s'amuse et peint démystifier le
côté conte faut être sérieux - choix
sérieux danville jeu sérieux quand j'ai
une job à faire mais j'ai pas de goût
d'être sérieux malgré que les gens me
voient comme ça puis j'accepte qu'on me
voie d'une phase plus sérieuse parce que
c'est ce que je représente
mais autrement moi je ne suis pas
sérieux je m'amuse envie je prends soin
de ma santé puis c'est ce qui est
important
enfin pu même quand j'étais en affaires
l'entraînement pilat le prendre soin de
notre santé est important c'est puis on
le voit de plus en plus moi je crois pas
qu'un homme d'affaires qui pèse 250
livres qui est belle d'anna qui fait de
la haute pression peut être performant
derrière son bureau
en avoir moins en moins de 50 quand même
un bon exemple des nouveaux hommes
d'affaires si on veut rester en forme et
en santé qui prend une équipe des moins
bonnes équipes de vie c'est ça parce
qu'avant et est on est on a des images
de gros monsieur qui séchait que leur
cravate
ouais mais c'est plus ces [ __ ] mais
surtout si tu veux un exemple des
employés petit vu que d'avoir des
employés qui sont équilibrées qui sont
performants parce que tu veux la faire
non seulement un exemple tu veux être
performant faisaient la une en tête les
pics là ils prendront pas de boisson un
vin de compétition il mangera pas de
burgers il va faire attention à ce
qu'ils mangent tout ce qu'ils vont
manger c'est du pétrole pour qu'ils
aillent plus vite à un homme d'affaires
on est dans une course
donc si tu veux performer soit l'esprit
réveiller se voit des concurrence
emmenée qu'être capable réagis tu sois
performant
donc s'ils souhaitent performant pour
trimestre du pétrole et 4 quand je
m'envole jam le jeu mature qu'avant je
mangeais du griot je mange ici un jour
faire un joubert avant ou après puis je
vais performant avant de faire quelque
chose fait donc c'est la même chose
comme homme d'affaires
tu pas t'endormir à 3 heures de l'après
midi et a enfilé deux buts un café après
dîner mais on serait tenté par exemple
de mettre le temps un homme d'affaires
qui commence maintenant qu'il irait au
jam il faut je mets tout mon temps dans
l'entreprise une offensive
c'est complètement fou les hommes
d'affaires qui performent le plus sont
ceux qui sont aussi en bonne forme en
j'ai fait une complicité une compétition
qui s'appelle the world gets you donc le
sio le plus en forme de saynètes bon
c'est américaine
il y avait invité paquet de monaco par
tous mais finalement on était des
canadiens des américains
hugo du mexique les autres les absentes
a donc su que son poids et ce christ est
redevenu la tablette 7 leur appartenait
aussi c'étaient tous des entreprises ou
fait d'avoir un chiffre d'affaires au
moins de 10 millions y est si ou
d'entreprises enfin que j'étais l'homme
aux partenaires aussi on était les labos
et honnêtement fallait être fort
mentalement que je forme écoute c'était
une compétition au weltklasse c'était
quoi les épreuves y avait six épreuves
ça a duré trois jours
il y avait planète même moi je suis
parti mais mon partenaire et m'avait dit
françois c'est sûr personne votre bat
c'est impossible
les pharmas natation efforts à course
est assez correcte en vélo impossible
que quelqu'un vous êtes capable de
battre ça se peut pas oui à 9,7 me battu
ses droits elle aucune d'existence
si notre natation savais que c'était les
jeux des pompiers tous les jeudis
policier est allé je les avais moi-même
mais les jeudi 6 h à l'époque ils ont
fait il y aurions commencé à faire ça tu
peux le faire aussi maintenant sur les
courses nascar le cios tu fais donc ils
veulent démontrer cette organisation là
que si au challenge puis ils veulent
démontrer que on peut gérer une grande
entreprise et est en forme et bon je
vous ai parlé tantôt de mon frère à hors
caméra de la vitesse qui roulait il ya
un code la boxe appelaient mme martin
celui que dans la compétition et aux 10
km soirée trois épreuves 50 km de vélo
le matin par de nouvelles après midi de
la main aux 10 km la course élimination
donc c'est un parcours de 600 m et 20
premiers tours je pense qu'on n'a pas le
droit de dépasser d'un cinq derniers ne
doit se dépasser puis le dernier
toujours éliminé à chaque tour à chaque
tokyo la première le premier 50 km de
vélo aussi les 25 premiers tours on suit
mais cinq derniers tours ont été 25
donc les gens sont éliminés quand j'ai
vu le gars partira course j'avais juste
un bon courage
j'ai vu que mon frère le machines de
course il faut pas dépasser personnes
pour accélérer il doit manger comme si
on était des enfants d'école
après c'est quoi son c'est quoi sa
compagne c'est une compagnie et à l 8 à
boulder colorado y avait deux choses qui
l'avantagerait en technologies met en
[Musique]
avant des jeunes
villas boas qui avait déjà l'abattage
genre nécessaire qui dans des chambres
pour l'été la fête qui avait déjà cet
avantage la piste super athlète est ce
un bel esprit compétitif parce que je me
suis rendu compte malgré nancy ce jeu là
que des hommes d'affaires qui sont
extrêmement successfull sont des
méchants loser parce que on avait le
droit y prenaient les cinq meilleures
épreuves sur six et peu de gens sont des
bons joueurs donc lorsqu'il n'arrivait
l'épreuve de natation
iago qui se bécotent libres et justes 5
je le fais pas on regarde ma force pour
le 10 km le cerveau sans danger on
essaie ça n'aurait pas ce que les autres
peuvent ni ne veulent pas donc sur 25
ans les jeux 6 ou 7 qui a pris le départ
les autres sont toutes fraîches et
dispos pilotons feeling danger on est
dix minutes après sa fausse étape et 10
km de course
moi j'ai fait comme méchant tu gagnes de
lugo puis martin qui a gagné lui a dit
alors moi je veux démontrer tout le
monde que je suis le meilleur dans
toutes les compétitions je le fais ils y
ont corrigé les lions ont changé les
règlements lé d'après foot face au moins
50% de l'épreuve pour qu'elles soient
comptés sinon de 0.1 concert 12 euros
brut parce que moi je savais que j'avais
le bi poin les chercheurs natation bien
notre doc avait été sur l'équipe
canadienne olympique américaine s'est
reprise on avait deux kilomètres à
faible giga moi je remplace aussillon je
loge pour je ne sais même pas de le
battre il vaut mais il va m'avoir on a
fini deuxième plus a fini premier
j'achète points mais moi j'ai donné
énormément de juin pas que je me serais
il ya des losers il ya des mauvais des
mauvais payeurs joueur donc
mais ça c'est un portable l'année passée
j'ai craint statut facebook et j'ai
comme comme on discute le l'importance
les temps forts tout en étant notre la
face on veut performer et agok vient
boire puis prince aussi large dj dit
regarde c'est moi ok mais ça c'est moi
le matin de février lorsque tu écris ton
post facebook puis
rien de méchant différence et du web
depuis quatre mois j'ai perdu fondé du
livre et il dit le plus de ton post est
lui l'aï je me suis regardé j'ai fait
comme je suis un groupe et je dors
l'après midi et je le vois encore
aujourd'hui est encore aux james matin
il a alors je vois ça fait un an et demi
puis il se maintient en forme théâtre
les fouilles mais ils me remercient moi
j'ai rien fait juste des gammes ce pas
performé c'était profond puits jumeaux
si je faisais partie de ces gens là
aucun moment donné tu te réveilles mois
25 ans le report du 32e je pèse 180
livres mais je faisais 200 livres mais
que de gros et s'en rend pas compte
moi je finis universités je commence à
travailler puis tu veux bien faire puis
la mentalité travailler tout le temps où
fait partie des deux des moeurs que je
n'y crois pas je crois pas du tout et
les mandats ni je travaille je trouvais
au gouvernement puis invoqué un collègue
de travail qui par ospina braden veille
le jeune je regarde je n'ai même pas
lui-même chercher le gros de la baie des
anges mais n'était pas rendu compte que
je te rends du groupe
parce que bon c'est pas mon temps à
regarder mais roanne je portais des 36
200 livres une bedaine léger fait non
non moi je vis pas comme ça ce sera
c'est pas moi et c'est le jeu commence à
courir puis là je dis non le site
important de d'en regarder ce qu'on
mange et de s'entraîner on n'est pas
fait pour être assis dans un bureau
convives il se peut se raconter
n'importe quoi
on est des animaux a bien ok donc lui en
bougeant pieds en marchant en courant
c'est ça donc faut bouger puis ça fait
partie sinon on voir un paquet de
maladie puis ces enjeux on le voit à
chaque campagne électorale il parle on
remet de l'argent santé oms va faire si
ce sont toujours en train de régler la
problématique à la fin la problématique
se règlent paulo le problème se règle
très jeune avec des habitudes de vie qui
sont importantes à mettre en place c'est
que le béton jet d'épongé l'eau qui
coule partant à place de fermer de
robinet ben c'est sotchi les gens s'en
rendent pas compte c'est important on ne
se projette pas négociable je m'entraîne
tous les jours
à moins de choix est malade je
m'entraîne achats les mots je suis au
djembé entraîneur georges temps très
court et je fais l'activité une fois par
jour - finalement faire deux fois
je vais en faire deux fois mais ça fait
partie de ma vie d'abord faire partie de
ma vie jusqu'à nash ou et puis capable
c'est important et ça me rend performant
crois moi que y'a des fois que tu es des
fois ci fait pour sortir wecht quoi
nintendo du matin la dernière via m'a
laissé tomber la magie me coucher j'ai
le goût mais je n'en ressens un club de
maïs a fait 23 ans que je commence ma
23e année cette année piti parce que le
mot jeu dangereux lundi mercredi
vendredi
bell jeudi soir des fois la matinée
l'important pour moi d'aller nager que
d'aller boire sans fin il ya des femmes
qui boivent raisonnablement mais ceux
qui m'appellent c'est parce que les
gones a fait l'espoir études au
secondaire mais primaire et secondaire
puis la grosse majorité des gens avec
qui on se condense parade sud il ya le
presqu'aucun qui ont dérapé qui ont pris
une mauvaise tournure parce que la fed
fasse pas de même
tu peux pas te permettre des excès de
pouvoir mettre des trois heures qu'il
faut que ce soit une simple income ce
donc d'effacer jeunes justement dans ce
cas se présentent à vie mais aucun os
pour commencer dans le fond mais non bis
l'important c'est d'avoir une discipline
comme l'homme mon garçon plus vieux de
sept ans il vient de commencer cégep
il vient de commencer une job et hervé
15 heures par semaine et c'était juste
mais tu devrais travailler depuis midi
la moyenne banier dit mme apache est
finie secondaire les dix que je fais le
secret des soudeurs et mais le samedi
matin à 7h factice et d'un côté c'est
parfait parce qu'ils ne travaillent pas
pour moi est de 2 est obligé de se lever
vers mon père
non le magasin havrais lui faut que soit
la satar c'est une discipline
c'est important de se mettre une
discipline peu importe ce qu'on fait si
on veut réussir ça peut pas cheap pour
réussir ta vie en ayant pris discipline
c'est impossible à moins des tangos
hyper chanceux du même les perches ans
se sont disciplinés pareil c'est parce
que certains dire que même en affaires
ou en sport ont été chanceux toyer il
rien de similaire de travail sur dix ans
les gens vont dire hey toi et été
chanceux
ça fait dix ans que je est plus que tu
travailles dans l'ombre
c'est même dans le sport c'est le même
temps les uns vers sid au même point
final si tu veux réussir quelque chose
tu dois travailler plus fort que les
autres
tout simplement parce qu'on est dans un
monde concurrentiel de façon régulière à
tout les jours il ya de la concurrence
partout dis toi que si t'as pas de
concurrence c'était vraiment une bonne
glace parce que c'est pas de concurrence
et que pas de marché puis d'ailleurs la
preuve 1 % des entreprises qui ferment à
tout simplement parce que le produit qui
ont mis sur le marché ou le service qui
of ne répond pas aucun autre besoin de
l'idée était bonne que le leur c'est toi
tu peuvent très bien avoir un problème
qui viennent à toi qui es maicon c'est
surtout le monde a eu la bonne idée j'ai
ma bonne idée je me lance en affaires
mais taiseuse monde pour toi petit job
ou b ci-dessus il la plus grosse erreur
de tout ça c'est que lorsque tu une
bonne idée qu'est ce que tu veux faire
toi la loi parce que legault et ph
regarde mon idée est bonne en maudit lui
les items qui a pas de décevoir
puis ça fait des années qu'ils foutent
lance en affaires fait qu'ils faisaient
et gentille des thonidés aspire kaki
dispo paye là il est en train de tuer
s'avoue pas de la merde mais je sais pas
parce que vu puisque aux gens j'ai dit
si haute idée si bonne que ça je fais
souvent la référence avec un bar de sa
volonté une nouvelle barre de savon au
lait de chèvre bondi à écouter est
vraiment meilleur la revente et amis des
ennemis vont tout en acheter une
première fois la barre de savon
tout le monde aime ça mais finalement ce
club et ça sent pas bon staff à la
faculté jaïn et 10 et écoute ton savons
il put à tabarre non je ne peux pas peux
pas l'aider parce que l'otan
l'entreprise c'est ton bébé c'est
l'oclctic un des fleurons de notre
entreprise notre bébé qu'as tu commences
à te lancer ton entreprise c'est tombé
but sur la défendent bec et ongles si ph
te dit que l'entreprise a pas de là le
cas où tu crois qu'on produit tu
écouteras peau tu vas aller voir
quelqu'un d'autre votre courir après je
sois prêt la personne jusqu'à temps que
quelqu'un dise et bons plans trait
dessus mais le dit que c'est bon dont
j'ai raison donc je vais me lancer en
affaires le tu bouges pendant quatre à
cinq ans le mot nazi dont je décolle pas
un espace qui avait pas de marché pour
on produit tout simplement s'était fait
mal conseillé donc moi je sais que jojo
j'ai dit si votre famille croit vraiment
vous au lieu qu'à 10 propre et demandé
leur don de l'argent s'ils croient
vraiment là ils vont te crois vraiment
qu'ils peuvent faire de l'argent avec
toi ils vont te le donne et le seul le
st100 bias le bpa se lovent monique de
besoin s'ils croient vraiment que tu es
un thé la bonne personne et doute un
vraiment bon produit crois moi quand je
dis que les gens c'est pas l'argent qui
était important au début tu vois on
envoie de l'argent l'argent votre
arrivée par magie c'est vraiment quelque
chose de miraculeux
c'est le sujet parfait pour faire le
saut vers les dragons parce que c'est
quand même quelque chose qui t'a mithois
vraiment médiatique quoi c'est ça qui te
fait d'apparaître comme une figure de
culture populaire si on veut pour les
jeunes puis quand tu étais dans les
dragons cette puce principe le sait que
si ton idée est bonne
tu vas avoir de l'argent tu vas avoir du
financement et du monde qui vont être
intéressés par tomber web et soit la
première année que j'ai fait les dragons
qui était la première saison en même
temps des dédales et du dragon g je
regardais que l'idée je me dis à magas
une bonne idée me fous de la personne
moi je capable gérer son entreprise
je trouve le locle la personne qui
présentait les je m'en foutais au début
c'était l'idée la bresse est bon je me
suis ramassée à vendre les cordes à
linge et une fin de semaine la première
entreprise investit avec guetta frigon
c'est une carte du clip on se ramasse
des kiosques à vendredi
c'est complexe
cc c'est complexe puis
quand je vois donne un exemple concret
de cette année que j'étais dragon éviter
une année cette année j'ai fait un deal
aller à l'écran syrie mariano on est
passé proche d'un deal
ça tombe à l'eau la semaine passée ok ce
que quand tu dis qu'un à l'émission voit
que tu dis ok moi je remarque s'est pas
fait c'est comme une lettre d'intention
c'est comme si on compare soit plus
jamais été sur tender c'est comme sujet
dirait quelqu'un et gardons et tu as mis
la pression sur atta première beit ommar
au restaurant sa clique encore
après si tu commences à fouiller le
papier baptisé hobo est ok j'aime pas
son passé finalement ça marchera pas où
j'ai assez d'argent donc y est tout il
ya tout ce qui se passe là 90% du temps
que les gens viennent à l'émission on
connaît rien dessus absolument entrer
c'est la première fois que vous entendez
parler de ce qu'ils vont elles celle de
marie on sait aucune idée que c'est un
jeune fille arrive ci dessus en cas
large
on ne sait rien du tout les commencent
leur pitch en or qui sont intéressants
puis moi moi je n'oublie jamais que
c'est un show télévision jeu là pour
m'amuser aussi puis je veux que les gens
écoutent il ya des bonnes répliques
donc je me dis tout le temps comment je
peux faire tourner ou deux phrases
chasse est toujours enceinte show télé
nous le nez dedans et d'où la première
année manuge a envoyé des quelques
platitudes que je trouvais drôle mais
que les jeunes connaissent impôts donc
quand par terre le journaliste chant
terrienne la parade la du soleil au pti
on ne le dragon bas vous donc la même
amende
cdg été identifiés de suite la drague
ont bien vu que j'ai vu que j'accepte
quand même accepté là je l'accepté puis
je l'embarqué parce que c'est vrai que
je te veux c'est vrai que si tu arrive
devant moi tu aimes demandé 100 mille
dollars pitt est pas prêt à ce niveau
passait d'un quart d'heure mais c'était
pour l'heure tout est comme ça dans la
vraie vie mais s'il est un shooter dans
la vraie vie si tu te rendras pas me
rencontrer
accessoirement voyons il n ya pas de
trop mais l'obligation de répondre c'est
un email non sollicitée si je vois que
ça de la leur c'est moi qui décide si je
réponds aux gens où je réponds pas aux
gens puis j'en reçois tellement que des
fois les jeunes dès web ne me répond pas
mais j'ai garé dans ta décision de
m'envoyer un mail d'un partenaire ma
décision te réponde m'appartient tout se
sait pas combien j'en reçois et quand
j'embarque dans des discussions que les
gens jouent brisbane
mais quand j'ai un bac n'ose pas une
bonne des moyens je vais te montrer
qu'elles sont bonnes dit ce n'est pas
moi je trouve que c'est une bonne idée
puis j'en reçois des mails encore
aujourd'hui 3 4 par jour
ouais de personnes qui pillent tuent des
idées oui ouais encore c'est par
l'entremise à facebook par l'ademe et
instagram par l'entremise de textos
d'un peu partout de rien masqué d'euros
c'est que c'est pas juste des idées ma
voix mes photos ont été volées de mon
compte instagram pour voler c'est
disponible mais là une panoplie de go
qui ont décidé d'utiliser mes photos je
vais le prendre comme un compliment pour
arnaquer des femmes sera votre argent
hockey et cohérence c'est vrai voir les
messages une box que j'ai sur ma page
facebook puis d'instagram c'est à tous
les jours deux à trois femmes par jour
qui se sont fait arnaquer
pour toi briser mes photos prennent des
photos sous mango fille garde besoin
d'argent
amman et kaka qui vient pour voir de
l'argent les femmes commencent à google
et les images se positionne logiciel qui
existe parce qu'il m'a on le trouve
c'est tout des français bien entendu
qu'un bête tout lyon john et écoutez je
trouve ça triste affaire mais j'en
reçois trois à quatre par jour des gens
que tu dises mon profil je peux plus
rien faire le jeu
cette façon des fois je signale à
facebook plus facebook me dis là tout
est beau tout est beau oui c'est moi
même et donc geagea a abandonné le
projet mais bon run aux entreprises
c'est que les gens me me mettant dans le
dragon on ne sait rien ils descendent on
aux édiles tout est beau le la job
commence
première étape background chèque c'est
quoi ton background cheikh savoir te
fais des vols a toujours fait ça y est
tu te tue d'être une contravention
samedi à waimes et schmidt
j'ai eu des d'étiquettes de vitesse
hockey a eu combien le l'un des vrais
comme étant devenues peu près 20 des
deux dernières années
c'est quelque chose qu'on propose en
fait ça me donne des idées à partir du
personnage là de l'avancement il ya un
gars qui avait fait il y avait eu cette
poursuite pour et contre lui donc l'eau
stockée pas d'accord avec de l'argent
pour delà de l'argent bien entendu il se
fait poursuivre où ils poursuivent dans
tout est ok je touche pas ça y est notre
corps lui avait un
[Musique]
il ya fait de la prison pour en fait
c'est d'abord il ya eu décès de marie
guano là ça sent bien légal mais il ya
fait quand même cinq ans de prison
sound avait de l'alluré mais bon ça mais
il n'y a pas quelque chose comme ça
qu'ils sont éliminés rapidement
il ya eu le background chez lui c'est
pour ça que c'est important de fond de
faible risque et denain nous dit un peu
quel genre de personnages ont tant de
personnages qui est devant moi passent
normalement lorsqu'on cherche un
partenaire
quelqu'un qu'on connaît quelqu'un qu'on
connaît depuis longtemps qu'on impose à
face au background chèque on le connaît
on le sait comme acquis moi je ne
connais pas donc c'est vraiment un match
qui tendrait de se faire rapidement
puis je veux m'assurer ce qu'il en est
des kits vous développez une relation
qui travaillent avec lui confiant de
confiance puis quelqu'un avec un kit un
minimum d'atomes crochus ou si je mange
mais j'attends crochus ces défis cdc se
détermine rapidement parce que tu parle
à quelqu'un en qui voyagent pas eu du
fun ouais ok c'est moi le départ si je
t'aime à nouvelle orléans avec un paquet
d'investisseurs qu on se posait comme
qu'elle s'y résoudre se poser comme
question c'est quoi notre critère de
choisir un partenaire puis la sarthe et
je détestais l'autre affaire moi j'ai
dit les bosses les coutumiers ou chez
moi je veux dire au regard d'un
partenaire là je te regarde du tout goût
de faire affaire que toi ou attendu des
bonnes tout est beau on va faire de
l'argent où tout est beau mais là je me
pose une question moscou toute la fin de
semaine au chalet tout goûter voire
matin avec les cheveux pour ce faire une
omelette ensemble puis qu'on se parle
ville plus du beau temps pour preuve le
samedi soir ce la réponse est non tu
seras jamais bon partenaire c'est parce
que quand ça va bien d'entreprise tout
le monde est gentil tout le monde est
fin lorsque ça va mal tu veux mon
appartenance et des amis sait déjà que
je goûte pas c'est autre chose que de
travailler avec eux s'est fait que donc
il ya cette partie si l'on apprécié les
états financiers
il ya des étapes pour arriver qu'un deal
souhaite aux dragons de background
cheikh ngane sa tombe l'eau et déjà
qu'ils sont venus bien finalement je
peux le goût d'avoir des investissements
chez changé d'idée donc ça tombe là
aussi
après ça tu regardes financier au bois
et aux caisses pas propre à nettoyer sa
lutte en pot ça tombe encore n'ont qu'un
paquet d'étape
il ya des fois ce sera jusqu'à la fin
aussi ça donne des bons et des
entreprises j'ai fait écho récréo jean
lissague au centre-ville
maintenant que fois la voile le stade
lui aussi m'a fait remarquer que dio est
lui venu une voix belle histoire
vraiment c'est un goût de la rue puis
vient d'écrire un livre sur son histoire
symbole qu'était vraiment dangereux que
si relevé
il ya eu deux mauvaises et et puis
populeux voyez ces petits vélos puissent
et ségou et puis il y avait pas voir la
voile en ce temps là il vient de voir
lady dragon pig été très touché par son
histoire
on dit oui on embarque dans le regard de
ses états financiers faisait beau et si
j'embarque avec toi faut que je prenne
ma maison garanti ton chat l'amant
garantie ton auto giga marque je peux
pas de face à l'état non plus tôt moins
deux requins là je pas là pour la vie de
jeux gascons votre frère m'a donné mon
comptable à temps plein on veut remettre
de l'ordre dans ses affaires
le comptable de l'elysée d'épuiser moi
je te donnerai pas d'argent pour faire
une garantie ce projet pour te sortir de
la marmotte recherché après je le
garantis
mais je peux potage peu moins 30 des
actions de la compagnie se serait pas
correct forme de notes pas on a garanti
ses affaires ont bien été on a levé la
garantie peut le faire maintenant besoin
de lier des cas comme ceux qui sont
suspendus chocolatées aux bons mots
alexandre taillefer guetta et moi on a
mis chacun 100 milles dans l'entreprise
dix-huit mois plus tard on a récupéré
notre 100000 donc on a un émis 300 mails
au départ dix mois plus tard
l'entreprise faisait huit cent mille
pièces de vente d'une mois plus tard
faisait 5 millions chef de vente
il y avait une perte de 500 à 1000 il y
avait un profit de 1.2 million dans le
débat parfait on vous restructurez de la
plus besoin de nous racheter nous
puisons racheté puis en même temps on a
fait on a fait 300 à 1000 plus 5000 dans
le chef de chocolat sur 18 mois 5000 $
de chocolat sur 18 mois là aucune idée
quand max et du chocolat chaud sporades
jusqu'à l'aube
g20 avant d'aller à des organismes à des
amis jsc beaucoup chocolat non je mets
donc elle est belle histoire qui tombe
bien cette année j'ai fait syrie mais
rihanna on pensait avoir un deal puis
j'ai un moment qu'on enregistre pas de
casse ils m'ont signifié la semaine
passée que y'a voulaient plus y ont pas
que ça n'arrive pas qu'il voulait pas
faire que nous ayons ils ont assez
d'argent finalement que j'aurais aimé ça
travailler avec eux autres honnêtement
je sais quelque chose que je voulais
vraiment faire avec christiane sa peau
sap a donné puis syrie qui me back et
j'aurais aimé ça que ça posera pas de
l'aimer c'est pas grave les gens disent
tu es tu déçu pour moi je suis jamais du
sud pour faire a dit je mets plus d u 10
u je suis même pas déçu quand je perds
de l'argent dans un deal j'assume le
respect phone même année c'est à moi de
gérer maurice accueille en as émis le 29
qui savent vole de ses propres ailes ce
continent m c'est mon problème mais pour
moi c'est ça fait parti du rire c'était
en affaires sur dix entreprises que je
m'investis le sceptre vont tomber de
toute façon c'est de même la la la la
l'esthète cycle de sept qui vont mourir
rapidement
il y en a deux qui vont être propre et
pme doit être un coup de circuit fait
que quand tu l'as en entreprise
avoir un coup de circuit comme j'ai eu
que les centres d'appels c'est excellent
d'avoir un deuxième c'est assez
difficile donc je vois avec booth missy
ça va être mon deuxième coup de circuit
même m'a donné foot accepte que
peut-être que je sais pas tout le temps
ce non plus puis donné demain je serai
heureux parce que après bosmie la
politique n'intéresse et mes enfants
vont
vont voler de leurs propres ailes donc
il va moins besoin de moi donc je veux
pouvoir voyager ou faire la politique
faro tous tu parles distillerie est ce
que tu avais ce que le projet
m'intéressait particulièrement parce que
tu un attrait pour ces choses là mais
j'ai toujours est ce que tu aurais voulu
avoir des parts dans une série
oui j'ai depuis le début des lieux du
dragon qui me demande quel type
d'entreprise parce que la production s
est de nouveau les entreprises qu'on
voit du coup de coeur pour investir
c'est si on veut si tu vas des batailles
de dragon fortement des entreprises que
les dragons ont le goût vraiment non moi
j'aime ça j'aime sa façon
si rory teague et son regard comme cette
année le disent ils et mariana je vais
le factuel c'est 250 milles pour 10 pour
ça je voulais le factuel et cristiano le
vaut pas beaucoup a nommé christian
germain me disait tout le temps parce
que tu veux tu investis cet accord et sa
beauté mois par margaret et tout investi
je le regarde avec un air hautain mais
c'est juste pour l'écurie falaye deux
seuls jeux fait seul gars c'est trop
petits les faits seuls puis a besoin
mais tenterait de le fait que toi je ne
m'intéresse pas puis bon une bataille
pseudo expliquer mais un moment donné à
l'envoyer une phrase plongée vu le
sourire en face des gauchers fait comme
et ça fait huit ans que je vois une
entreprise comme ce puits est la vienne
me l'enlever en un clic
il a dit oui mais ça n'a pas marché
oui j'ai toujours parce que et des
entreprises qu'on fait qu'ils sont qui
répond à un besoin
un centre d'appels c'est pas sexy c'est
paul fans savaient pas besoin c'est
payant 10 syrie une brasserie une
microbrasserie je parle c'est parce
c'est à moins qu'il soit alcoolique fini
que tu bois un buteur le matin pour te
saouler la gueule
la plupart du temps on boit pour
célébrer quelque chose on prend un verre
par plaisait pour célébrer les routes
avec des amis pour le goût de célébrer
quelque chose de positif et c'est le fan
est dans des entreprises qui vendent du
positif 0 de lille ayant des des
alcooliques
c'est pas correct il souffre
c'est vrai mais la plupart du temps ci
du bonheur que tu veux et c'est le fun
et dans une entreprise qui à chaque
produit qu il ya quelqu un qui est
content de l'acheter ni sur moi ça me
fait ça ça me fait passionnés puis
j'aime travailler que le vivant il reste
qu'à partir de grains de partir de nos
données puisque et le houblon mélange
avec de l'eau des levures dont il du
vivat là dedans tu créé quelque chose
qui combres consommer plus tard moi ça
ça va lui même ce genre de chose le
jeune terre je fais poursuit doublons je
vous puissiez 300 doublons sont encore
21 après 3,1 et imac gun syrie gantois
victoire qui revient en fait une
impression c'est la création dans son
style plus un créateur qu'un
gestionnaire beaucoup plus oui et oui
c'est ce qui m'a même puisque moi j'ai
toujours pensé que j'étais moi je suis
en comptabilité je travaille à
l'informatique et pour moi j'étais un
gosse derrière un écran tout le temps
j'ai jamais pensé jeter créatif jusqu'à
temps que je lise un livre qui s'appelle
créatif du world's de jérôme lehrer je
pense on me dit qu'ils étaient copiées
puis l'enlever de même reste un bon
livre et je me suis rendu compte que
c'est un peu les hommes d'affaires là
c'est les gens parmi les gens les plus
créatifs parce que pour moi un homme
d'affaires
une femme d'affaires c'est comme
cuisinier et ouvre la porte du frigo
puis elle regarde notre frigo il dit le
cuisiner vos héros parfait je suis zen
avec quelque chose par la faim le
meilleur cuisinier
tu vas aller manger chez des amis se
faisait michael j'ai toujours fait
quelque chose de bon à rien fait et je
suivais utiliser des ingrédients
iliad est capable de mixer ensemble de
mettre des épices la bonne cuisson
c'est mike godfrey manger chez des amis
c'est toujours bon de manger chez nous
pas mal tous les rebonds mais un homme
d'affaires c'est la même chose celui qui
réussit c'est pour celui qui est la
meilleure recette si celui qui est le
plus créatif parce que tu arrive le
matin c'est sûr que sous l'auvent d'un
fiscaliste
ils coûtent trop cher je le passe temps
plein c'est ce que sera à voir tomber
leurs vendeurs mettent à poil meilleur
vendeur parce que peut-être pas les
moyens de le permettre mais à la fin
puis tonton go qui fait la livraison
c
présenté le matin donc qui réussissait
le bafa qui arrivent le matin puis il
peut shirli rentrer dans son bureau pour
servir les clients où il faut être
créatif passe est quand même de créer
une recette gagnante pour la journée et
c'est ça qui est un homme d'affaires on
est des heurts extrêmement créative à
notre façon mais pour moi aux avants
créative le dire artistiquement
donc ça faisait était capable de peindre
t'es capable de dessiner été capable
d'écrire des poèmes
non on est créatif avec les jeunes qui
sont devant nous parce qu'on gère déjà
et s'il ya quelque chose qui est le plus
difficile comme homme d'affaires de
gérer une entreprise sait gérer les gens
c'est compliqué de bois voir juste cinq
employés ou mais l'employé tous les
mêmes problèmes
d'autres jours d'absentéisme toujours
quelqu'un un problème à la maison c'est
correct ça fait partie de notre job de
les encadrer et de les aider mais il
reste que ces problématiques gérait déjà
les normes extrêmement pur extrêmement
complexe donc j'aime mieux créer que de
gérer des gens se sentent plus quatre
mois plus proche d'un artiste que d'un
comptable ou ça prend le bon mix des
deux en orge plus proches de l'artiste
que d'un comptable c'est ça j'ai souvent
pensé que je tends comptable mais je 0
patience pour regarde la fin c'est que
je souhaite est là de reconnaître et de
lire extrêmement rapide des chefs tels
kiki moment je regarde un chiffre je
regarde le plan d'affaires j'ai compris
puis jouer à autre chose maintenant je
parlais que la personne le comptable lui
va analyser vous regardez pitel colonnes
j'ai pas de format façon j'ai étudié le
dap parce que la réalité y avait des
belles femmes pieds 50 réalité la raison
parce que je voulais faire dans vie moi
je voulais au début et de vétérinaire
puis j'avais pas de patience pour faire
la sciences pures au cégep genou et
mature pour étudiants en sciences pures
venant de la campagne par vos sujets
après sept patients cela et je regardais
je m'affaire administration finance
comptabilité des belles filles en
comptabilité ferme adressée très partie
des choix de carrière qui sont
complètement immature mais qui au la
carrière
que pense y était pour avoir alors je
vais tenter moi je dis je pensais
travailler sur le parquet de la bourse
sorti de l'école en 89 crash boursier
majeur en 87 personnes travaillent là
dedans c'est informatisé par la suite
moi je voulais aller très vite des
papiers comme ça se passe le temps en
temps des à sa chasse a changé je me
serais amorcé comme comptable j'aimais
posso une opportunité j'avais le goût
d'apprendre comme comptable je faisais
partie de l'informatisation
donc on me demandait bt jeune doit donc
tu connais l'ordinateur donc se connaît
notre santé notre programmeur donc j'ai
du moment où ce programme tant appris à
programmer jeanneret programmées comme
ça que j'ai fait qu'un maillot est sûre
s'ils font un petit cri fait avant de
politique créé quelque chose se fait par
une machine qui est donne quelque chose
à l'écran afin calcul que kita aurait
pris une éternité
j'ai découvert une passion pour ça et
j'ai fait partie de ma carrière là
dedans pas mal d'années bonbons et quand
je me sens sale affaire j'ai quand même
rester programmeurs longtemps parce que
j'aime sur puce travail du stress au
travail évitent donc j'ai dû développer
logiciels des centres d'appels qui vendu
aujourd'hui donc je pense 60 soit de 10
pays que la compagnie existe encore
depuis 2000 donc ça fait 18 ans qu'elle
existe qui est à ses rangs donc j'ai
découvert une passion comme
informaticien à bresso je ne pensais pas
moi c'est un gaucher né dedans quand
j'étais jeune me mettre devant une
caméra pour moi c'était les fans exposé
demain moyens navals mais voulait me
chercher je te pas capable jusqu'à pas
que parce qu'à valider rallonger fait
occupé presque parfait j'ai fait exprès
parce qu'à part fait pourquoi parce que
là une des réalisatrices partir de
productrice m'a dit françois qui devrait
faire notre choix et j'ai fait comme non
mouche pas de télévision et j'ai dit oui
quand même
l'équipe de télévision débarque chez
nous une semaine après et je me souviens
pourquoi que j'avais arrêté de faire des
compétitions en 2001 vraiment de jaja
2001 je savais en 2000 j'avais fait
énormément de compétition j'ai fait
toutes les triathlons et que toutes les
courses urvoy toute l'airé les choses de
natation radio septembre jusqu'à brûler
jules fr
aller le 10 km du parc lafontaine je le
faire en bas de 34 minutes donc j'ai dit
parfait je suis en forme je fais le
premier tome 5 km en 16 minutes qui
était déjà mon meilleur temps pas 35
secondes
j'ai arrêté de courir j'ai fini à pied
jeudi moscou plus jamais ma vie à me
taper plus j'ai couru je continue à
m'entraîner pour le fun le goût de faire
des compétitions
ça me tentait plus que le stress du dal
l'aide de l'avant compétition faut
l'avoir fait énormément de compétition
vous n'avez fait pour savoir le stress
immense lorsqu'était c'est un bloc de
départ qu'ils y aillent aux fourches
performe ceci que ça va faire mal
une façon inouïe ne s'est pas de
résultats tout à fait puisque tu penses
à faire des fois c'est pas le résultat
que que tu sais ça fait mal c'est tenter
comme ce que les caméras sont arrivés
cameron sont arrivés chez moi j'ai fait
comme pourquoi j'ai dit oui ça fait deux
fois que vos toilettes je cracherais pas
bon même année mais qu'est ce qui peut
servir à j'ai fait de l'agneau j'ai fait
un dessert à l'érable et mais la face
c'est que je me suis rendu compte comme
le garder des caméras ici j'ai fait
qu'il ya ici du plastique se marier ce
comme on se parle et tout de suite je
tombais dans un mode confiance la
réalisatrice hanny c'est que je optique
de ce moment donné ça s'arrête au québec
s'est dit mal à l'aise parce que ça lui
a mis à l'essai année à 10,6 c'est une
fille qui prêtent tout est juste assis
en entrevue devant elle et je regardais
c'était tout est un petit set dérange
seul à longjumeau ta km de calcutta cup
en tête de marcq morguard
ok ta gueule françois et on a même mis
en confiance m'a le fait de moi un
personnage plus grand que nature et je
leur job c'est leur job biel le bien
fait parce que ça m'ouvre des portes moi
j'allais là pour m'amuser je n'avais
aucune idée d'aller piller jamais
dépassé par là pour faire la division la
réponse est non j'étais quand j'ai vu
que c'était pas gêné devant la caméra
j'avais du fal j'ai donné du gaz au juge
quand j'ai vu déjà revu chez moi la
réalité si j'ai fait comme ailleurs
c'est quoi ta casting la jarre repos de
fans
donc je peux bouder outils dits belges
participent donc temps que je participe
je veux leur donner du gaz
j'avais compris que j'étais pour est une
des têtes d'affiché la fin de la semaine
assez rapidement par ça me parlait donc
plus pas plus eu la chance d'utiliser
son temps du temps d'écran puis là j'ai
fait comme ok je vais m'amuser
puis je vais envoyer mon faire comme si
c'étaient des amis puis les gens qui me
connaissent vont rire puis moi je
pensais que les gens qui me
connaissaient prêt-à-porter mais non
pour me retrouver au thème et que guy
laliberté avait d'impôt va côté de moi
la façon qui me décrivent à l'écran un
côté c'est drôle moi j y ai je me dis
ben voyons donc c'était qui les gens qui
me connaissaient aussi trouvé ça drôle
mais c'était ma première expérience avec
les réseaux sociaux je me souviens du
vendredi pêche avaient donné leurs oeufs
2 à france est l'une des participantes
et palerme à la réalité c'est que
c'était pas mangeable
il c'est moi je m'était donné cinq
revues 25 bayard le monde 5 6 puis
j'avais raté mon repos arrive des fois
je l'ait déjà reçu bénabar avec des
pires jeux les rater puis c'est pas bon
puis j'ai donné deux pseudos le monde
ont dit ok tu vois les riches
tu es qui pour juger c'est une concierge
la madame dont c'était les plantes et
une madame madame tout qui était même
madame tout le monde mais moi je viens
de vienne un milieu pauvre donc je suis
moi aussi je fais partie du peuplement
pense pas que je fais partie du peuple
j'ai de l'argent oui mais mentalement je
pas françois dr
arrêtez oui je prends soin de toi on
s'appelle pas comme ceux ci ont fait
manger mais c'est le meilleur qui gagne
mais c'est sa vie bon j'ai bien vu que
j'étais un personnage j'ai été détesté
royalement te coûter aux acheteuses pris
le vendredi 1 octobre ce week-end là que
ça a été diffusé je n'ai pas voulu
sortir de chez moi
jésus christ et surtout l'oeil à
quelqu'un comme corchia gueule je
regarde à page facebook s'était déchaîné
bear head on me réinvite jeu dur qui je
veux y aller on montrait côté de moi
moins baveux mais drôle que j'ai fait le
monde mais y est drôle ça gueulait ça
nous envient ben oui mettez les gens
vont vraiment juger sur un cinq minutes
qui doit y aller créant au complet
finalement pour te juger de tout entière
personne ne connaissait pas quelles
émissions faites en faisant j'aime les
commentaires de dire que les gens aiment
[Musique]
débattre de classe alors alors que c'est
pas sur le point d'annoncer si j'avais
écrit après ton passage à dominer vrai
quoi ce que tu parlais du puy le monde
mais c'est le risque d'inhalation
condamnation mais c'était pas seul point
du tout non mais puis si j'ai fait les
frais à tirât dernière map cette
question leur venue à cas de richard
martineau d'aidé mais t'es qui toi le
riche pour donner des leçons gens même
peu c'est même pas seul puisque j'ai
répondu puis je vais toujours répondre
c'est pas un riche qu'il parle c'est un
citoyen un père de famille 1 go qui fait
son épicerie qui pointe situation égard
on me dit que ça coûte ça du côté de
cette pièce puis moches les yeux fermés
là je sois né quinze pièces par semaine
pjanic est pas plus le point qui va la
manger puis je mange de la viande mais
il ya il faut apprendre à cuisiner puis
c'est ici ces dix pôles riches qui dit
oh j'apprenais que lundi que ces legault
qui leur est fait pareil même si j'ai
déjà connu ce pas parce que tu es riche
que s'attendent de plus dépenser
d'argent d'épicerie sèche cheveux quelle
femme que je vais avoir un j'aime ça
quand même cuisse
un repos puis le truc pas transformer
ses valeurs mais c'est quand cette
semaine je fais une ratatouille
ok c'est derrière compliqué à faire
ratatiner qu aux aubergines oignons
tomates piments bing hawn comme des
pistes forte pis mamelon la princesse et
goûte pas fait comme ailleurs que c'est
bon moi j'aime bien avoir mon mot juste
heureux comme un bel élan j'aime rendre
quelqu'un heureux en faisant quelque
chose de simple extrêmement simple qui
peut avoir de la côte du palais
ratatouille zahia sur sa faim c'est
simple ok donc pour moi faire bien à
manger c'est de faire plaisir aux gens
ça fait plaisir soi même mais fait
plaisir aux gens et c'est certain que si
j'achète la moitié de mes affaires j'ai
pas le même
les et je veux jouer mais je l'achetais
facile puis je le fais l'occasion mais
pour moi cuisine iep
j'ai du fun à face à ça et puis bon je
me fais souvent dit et qu'il reste aux
pourparlers
dès qu'il est riche pour dire aux gens
retournent travailler j'avais j'avais
déjà planté les gens de la construction
et ça si c'est un métier que tu ne dois
pas touchés il ya certaines choses que
sont extrêmement sensibles juste dire
aux étudiants d'arrêter de se plaindre
ils vont vouloir encore sa gueule
royalement loppsi c'est des choses
vraies sadio syndicats on n'a plus
besoin d'un syndicat des années et des
années aujourd'hui voici pourquoi il me
liront pas ils vont juste les le site
ils vont me démolit si je dis aux jeunes
que moi je fais mon épicerie de sang les
quinze pièces là je suis le gars est euh
ok mais des gratteux le général charles
chéreau même pourquoi pas avec 210
places dans une semaine
c'est certain que 6 après d'acheter du
stock chez cosco parce que j'entraîne
l'eau des puits forés pour trois ans en
avance avons acheté 200 dollars mais la
réalité c'est que je vais manger les
prochains
sa cote a rien du trio avant de
m'entraîner c'est ce que je vais manger
ça coûte rien je pourrai manger des
céréales peut de fait ça vous coûte et
ses pièces aux deux kilos de de grille
aux côtés des 99
j'en ai mal mais je vous en donner parce
qu'il est le gouffre plus beau ça coûte
là ça coûte rien puis c'est le fun ii 2
de réapprendre à cuisiner puis c'est
vrai les gens vont d'eux et d'élèves du
poulet c'est vrai que j'élève mes
poulets et poulet me reviennent 8 $
l'unité un coût élevé
trois poulets chez cosco ça coûte 21
dollars
ce qu'est donc ça coûte à peu près le
même prix allait acheter un poulet
entier c'est certain qu'ils achètent la
poitrine ça va coûter cher aux urgences
est aux platines
faites les cuire au complet fais ce que
les autres ont tous été végétarienne
c'est différent mais je ne ferme c'est
vrai que je ne ferme puis spots au monde
peuvent acheter leurs poulets sauf que
ça coûte à peu près le même prix chez
cosco les légumes l'hiver les légumes
mettant comme les ananas ou les avocats
je passe mon temps à les acheter puis
les jeter donc ça m'énerve d'acheter de
la bouffe
maintenant j'achète les anneaux congelés
simplement il goûte pareil d'action
décongeler jean haget jamais les avocats
c'est la même chose chez hachette
congelés parce que j'ai j'ai tout le
temps à toutes les fois que je me dire
qu'il faut jouer manitou je ne me force
à manger même journée s'est passée la
fusée proton et des gens cette smart
avec la bouffe
cette pile de glaner fier et puis des
fois c'est choquant ça va être spécial
mettons comme les bouquins les scandales
de cette épicerie l'eau c'est juste
arrivé lundi à fa l'épicerie mimi pistre
il s'était même pas le vrai épicerie
avec les doritos avait de l'eau que
j'achète même pas de lomé le rêve en
spécial puis avec goodbye ma facture sur
facebook
des fois je me disais il ya des fois tu
vois écrit quelque chose sur ce poste
cherche le trouble j'admets que j'avais
déjà répondu que je le fais pour cent
avec inspire ce film on m'avait dit que
les riches c'est possible - i quand je
me mets faction sur cinq est de 50
pièces
je m'attendais un peu à ce qui somme là
c'était de l'arrogance piette pas de
l'arrogance
c'était des bamouns pu porter garder
tout ce que j'ai acheté il y avait des
brillants spéciale à 80 social le monde
il faut juste faire manger des brocolis
c'est des fois il faut
j'aime bien brasser la cage pour faire
réfléchir les gens pour les insulter
pour faire réfléchir
et s'il ya quelque chose qui fait
réfléchir la population du québec
définitivement ce reportage l'autre
journal montréal de sa division alors on
voudrait des débiles parce que 1 sont
allés chercher quand même tu fais un
test ne va pas chercher de la bouffe
dans les banques alimentaires
c'est insultant un coût de l'argent
quand même pour payer tout juste à dire
aux gens de la moria désole le test on
peut pas le faire on n'arrive pas faut
pas voler de la bouffe dans les banques
alimentaires ceux qui vont des banques
alimentaires en ont vraiment besoin de
petits on n'y est pas avec soin pour moi
et deux
c'est le pot ce que les gens me parlent
le plus souvent encore puis en écrit
d'autres celui là il est élu par 4
millions de personnes c'est presque tous
les québécois qui ont été mis devant le
fait qu' on peut se nourrir ça que ça
coûte moins cher c'est certain si je
suis le guide alimentaire canadien est
qu à l'os par semaine puis tu vas
acheter de la viande en quantité
industrielle
parce que c'est ce qu'est le guide
alimentaire te dis parce que le lobby
derrière soit on dit que c'est ce qu'il
fallait qu'on manche
c'est en train de changer mais ça prend
du temps moi je le suis pas montre que
la nouvelle édition change des jeunes
changent ils vont enlever les produits
laitiers
c'est un porte parle encore mais ce nous
on tient avec ma copine en une chaîne
youtube qui ont fait des vidéos de
toutes sortes qui tourne autour du
véganisme en général puis la vidéo que
le plus panier importe ce qu'on a fait
maintenant un mois et demi après
occupation d'aubois ce que l'on traîne
des encore beaucoup lé mais c'est notre
épicerie à 50 dollars ouais on essaie de
faire une épicerie à 5 en dollars pour 2
puis on en eut trop tôt énergie
exclusivement de ses 50 $ l'heure
pendant deux semaines juste ce que de se
ranger à ses textes empreints de
beaucoup
ouais moi je m'entraîne encore vraiment
eu vraiment énormément on a fait
l'épicerie se moque t 50 et 53 puis il
en reste quelques personnes non pour de
la peau de bien rester après puis le
monde les commentaires sous la vidéo
c'était du monde
vous voulez l'essayer parceque on avait
trop de boeuf des fruits des légumes du
tofu coûts qui en est fait on a fait le
maximum est ce que le j'ai acheté des
républicains fera que s'arrêter moins
cher encore là mais on avait acheté des
légumineuses sec que tu fais raid raté
oui c'est ultra facile il y avait des
débits rouge des haricots noirs des pois
chiches
il y avait des lentilles on avait acheté
des portes on a acheté des euros scan de
tomates à 99 cents et la sauce tomate de
là dedans pression est allé à la
fruiterie on avait l'aude et notre
panier de fruits pour 25 pièces puis on
en est et on avait tout ce qu'il fallait
mais c'est cessole le truc tu es
oublions le fait que j'élève mes poulets
mais mes légumes
moi j'achète quand je vais au chalet il
ya là ça peut être beau va surtout pas
leur faire de la publicité mais il ne me
coûte rien et colas deux séries prend
son temps rabais et que tu me proche de
betteraves de 10 livres de coûts de
saint piat sont donc tous moyens
d'acheter pour pas que sa couche à
moitié depuis cette flotte deux fois je
me disais ah c'est si tu viens avec moi
pour mon fusil sarvi quasiment à une
pièce du repos le calcul bah oui tizi
dimanche travaux par jour 1 21 euro par
semaine mais ton très facile au t2 par 2
42 des collations la demande du stock en
masse pour retravailler dans la cuisine
c'est certain le sait mais c'est le
monde me disait moi j'ai pas le temps je
réponde une couple de fois comme état
par jour du post facebook sur instagram
sujet passionnant que j'avais dit je
garde au lieu de me répondre aux crises
non mais c'est coeur il ya moyen puis
honnêtement ça me rend pas du tout moi
je vais te faire [ __ ] une fois par
semaine puis je fais 2 2 3 avec puis
quand j'ai un patient chevaux faire
bouillir les eaux le savez de
végétariens mais je fait trois quatre
pots avec ça si je mangerai pas tout en
ligne mais des fois je vous en conjure
du poulet peu je peux le goût de manger
du poulet 3 3 4 jours allez mes appuis
je sais tu pas de garde motivé je sais
je suis plus flexitariens je trouvais
trouver exactement c'est que je veux
choisir de manger végétarien quand je le
peux mais je me priverais pas de manger
de la viande mais la viande rouge pour
moi un steak faut manger mais manger
peut-être une fois ou deux où j'allais
cet été comment je m'en veuillez pas de
viandes rouges en ville
manger autre chose ne sais pas ce que je
marche mais la plupart du temps ne pas
tutoyer c'est que des légumes
enfin que mais c'est cesser de faire des
choix
mais la mode est aux prêtes à manger et
il ya beaucoup de marketing son regard
des réseaux sociaux qu instagram
je pense que tout le monde des promos
code sur les est prête à manger ça coûte
sa place dans s'amène donc c'est juste
pour le plus juste le ce prix là donc ce
choix puis les gens qui sont pressés
mais c'est certain que les gens vont me
dit j'ai pas le temps la bête montréal
nate est peu cette semaine j'en entends
de 1,1 twitter le y avait deux villes
lorraines il travaille à saint jean sur
richelieu
c'est après 3h45 se rendent au travail
le mardi le premier aujourd'hui suivent
à la la fête du travail un que si tu
fasses un jean sur richelieu travailler
2 que si tu fais le rêve d'habiter s'y
trouvait saint-josse tricheurs ok ça
aucun bon ça c'est certain que si tu
penses 3h45 du matin soit pour ces trois
heures le soir d'un trafic de 7 heures à
ta journée qui passait dans le trafic et
bonhomme d'elle-même pleine nuit se
demande pour qui ces nuits mais la
plupart des gens se tord c'est comme une
hutte sommet l'étalement urbain est un
pas une problématique majeure mais c'est
surtout les familles qui vont c'est
qu'ils vont s'éloigner décembre parce
que ça
trop cher mais d'un côté leur qualité de
vie et pour leur côté super grande cour
avec leurs grands jardins fleurs piscine
vient même pas le temps d'en bénéficier
honnêtement ça cause des problèmes
routiers faux falloir rester si j'étais
politiciens en charge du transport je
rentrerai dans tête aux gens ayez un
pied à terre à montréal vivent ici la
semaine puis sortez la fin de semaine
avec un chalet ça va vous coûter moins
cher mais les gens acceptent pas
maintenant d'avoir un loyer moins cher
parce que parce que on était mind et que
la maison et l'investissement premier
qu'un couple doit faire c'est
complètement faux
c'est complètement faux c'est le pire
investissements qu'on peut faire mais on
le fait parce qu'on ne le goût d'avoir
une maison
point final le res ces les banques qui
nous ont lavé le cerveau que ça prenait
ça parce que ça coûte moins cher louis à
medias par moore mais 500 places par
mois que le parlement de la maison mais
tu peux trouver une place mais 500
places pour moi qui va te coûter moins
cher qu est ta maison tombe on gueule ou
en banlieue à 150000 parce qu'on parle
de la maison moyenne ça coûte cher avoir
une maison c'est un c'est un désir et
mais ce n'est pas un investissement
c'est coûte moins cher donnait de
l'argent at-on propriétaire que de gérer
ta propre maison mais les gens ne le
savent pas où donc s'arrêtera yves qui
pour un rêve qui devient un cauchemar
et après ça on n'a pas le temps de
cuisiner alors que si on rentrait dans
tête aux gens vivaient près de votre
lieu puis la fin de semaine
ailleurs à l'intérieur ça serait pas
d'être un luxe que peu tout le monde
peut se permettre par con mais c'est pas
non je pense que les gens sont peut-être
que la dup qui se trouvait seul à seul
job qui russes à se trouver toute la
maison c'est la seule qui était au prix
qu'ils étaient capables de saborder
aussi peut-être mais il va dépenser son
argent en gare aux éventuels mans il va
dépenser son argent à elle s'était pris
notre trafic
je m'excuse a fait trois heures puis
rendu cette heure et demie soit suspects
appel ta famille gay h voire et au fast
food en persan parce que je crève de
faim c'est que tout le paquet de parce
que les gens ne se rendent pas compte
et la qualité de vie en diminue alors
que parce que notre société audi que
c'est une famille ça te prennes maisons
sont des loups je teste pas de maison
pas une famille vit en appartement
les gens vont te poser au qu'est ce que
tu penses à votre maison bientôt
on nous vend du rêve là mais j'ai fait
le l'exercice parce que j'ai une leaf
publier bientôt et j'ai ça fait partie
d'un des vivaces que la maison est
encore un bon investissement
mathématiquement la réponse est non tout
simplement sinon à ne pas faire le faire
mais ce n'est pas l'investissement
quand on regarde la lune est économique
c'est sûr mais il ya des lunettes sous
laquelle regard des surveillants c'est
certain que leur il faut laver des
enfants avec une cour en arrière qui
peut secourir plus jouer
il ya aussi carl en balance oui mais les
villes ont des coûts aussi à offrir
parce que puis avec les crois moi que si
tu travailles ma tante à baie saint
girons petit travail à montréal
enquêtent à deux heures de route le
matin deux heures de route le soir
donc tes enfants là sont avec la
gardienne quand tu arrives soit que
quelqu'un te prépares-tu commence à
préparer ton scoot a passé toute la fin
de semaine en train de préparer des
radios pour la semaine enfin la bresle
le soir là deux des devoirs a préféré
quand tu arrives et tango ton en faire
on parlait lors des iphone et des ipad
sont soit écrasé dans le salon c'est la
réalité là la grande cour est un live
qui sert pas grand chose les soit si à
l'intérieur on bouge pas c'est si bien
évident que nos enfants ne bougent pas
si c'est un problème mais c'est une
réalité de notre société aussi je suis
d'accord que son peu tendre ajustements
mais cellule en commun on a des parcs à
montréal où est-ce qu'une réponse jouets
de cour et aussi dérangeante était
toujours en garde les enfants étaient
élevées à montréal dans rosemont j'ai
choisi un croissant
parce que je passe les enfants peuvent
jouer à l'intérieur j'avais une petite
couronne arrière et des parcs parc
maisonneuve à côté s'ils ont besoin de
bouger encore plus pour le vélo il pas
vrai que les villes manquent d'espacé
pour élever les enfants colas et 1,6 est
passé le rêve du groupe coop du bateau
c'est comme si sa présence auprès des
rues alors que ça prend pas ça pour être
sûrs dont le voyage annonce qui passe de
matt feuillette wever avait mon gros
pick up le bateau en famille au chalet
du fonds maintenant
j'ai fait ça y est tu fais parce que
c'est le rêve américain il rêve canadien
ça te prends ta maison dont camions dont
bateau mais tout ça c'est de l'argent
qui n'ose qui ne sert que très peu et
qui t'amène pas tant de plaisir que ce
type i l'argent les bébelles moi tu
crois peut-être parce que moi je croyais
boutebel jeu j'aime avoir des belles
mais je m'attends donc j'en achète plus
de bébelles parce que c'est plate forme
de s'essayer montre un peu cher quand
même je ne serai plus je faisais même
pas remplacés j'ai même d'une monde
moi j'ai plus de ce fait voler mais bon
je sais même pas remplacé n'ont rien à
leur quête marc acheter une c'est là que
le titanic mettant de leur avoir parce
que c'était un monde spécial mais alors
plus la même spécialité le même
signification lorsque je vais la
chercher mais j'ai plus le goût d'avoir
une connexion de mon film et rspo je
l'avais quotidien mais je dois encore
avec toi qui es l'étalement urbain est
pour moi une solution viable qui ont été
amis des petits en ville prendre
transports en commun utilisé les parcs
dit que justement d'aller à taper dedans
ligny trafics à chaque jour ce message à
nouveau c'est que ça n'a pas de bon sens
je sais pas qu'est ce que ces gens là
cherchent
qu'est ce qu'ils obtiennent en retour
c'est certain que moi de se mettre deux
heures entre la fiq matin au soir la
juge tout nouvel découragé personne la
mouche ou nouvelle mais je le sais pas
c'est l'fun mais je pense qu'au travail
puisse conserver juste depuis que j'ai
déménagé à montréal il faut que je
change les habitudes de vie parce que je
suis québec j'ai toujours ma voiture
parce que québec c'est possible de le
faire mais depuis je t'aime morial faut
que change vous êtes seul faut que je
prenne plus de transports en commun
parce qu'il est dans le trafic ça me tue
at il fait du yoga c'est s'amuser wise
ou google maps ou aux maps
je me déplace qu'avec ça se sait jamais
où des prix puis moi j'ai pas de goût
j'ai pas le goût de perdre montasser du
tablet 7 à l'eau je peux la faire à
faire autre chose
entre autres cuisiner c'est vrai je me
fais des jumelages prada fanny gibert
parce que j'aime ça c'est bon ma santé
puis j'ai eu le temps de le faire et je
prends moi je t'invite campagne free
spins good feel d'entre eux
l'antre de bon ben c'est comme entre 2
août un ted poe les services de la ville
qui tape à l'appel de la campagne
c'est un voisin un côté toile on le voit
est temps qu'on passe sur les autoroutes
la tablette en banlieue l'été des
voisins mur à mur la grande cour allait
juste 40 pieds le puits des x 25 ce
pauvre elle que les grandes courses est
foutue tes fans grande cote était de
voir un chat s'envole dans le fin fond
de la campagne avant la campagne sont
pas suspendus peu après selon des essais
avec avec l'internet d'aujourd'hui peas
et six de mieux en mieux accepté le
travail à la maison parce que les gens
surtout en l1 informatique oi on n'a
plus besoin de se présenter tout dans un
bureau dire à l'ol ou l autre et si on
travaille tous avec des ordinateurs la
plupart des gens moi j'ai des voisins
cas de montchanin campagne l'autre on
t'attend play une qui est traductrice
l'audit en informatique descend jamais
en ville
facetime importe quoi puis date uccle
mais se pose et on a perdu le temps de
faire livrer à faire on est on a perdu
le temps d'élever nos enfants on est
perçu le temps de faire à manger parce
que toujours une solution
il ya toujours un entrepreneur briac
dire que je trouve là donc il vaut il le
prête à manger est devenu extrêmement
populaire
donc si tout ça est toujours une
solution
quelque part nous enfants crient en auto
le nom ipad alors que la réponse devrait
comporter toi mais c'est la facilité tu
vois la tête d'un ipad branche aux
séducteurs
pis c'est comme cela que l'étalement
urbain c'est un des enjeux de quel type
à nantes on livre qui sont en octobre
définitivement l'étalement urbain et
encore est une problématique majeure de
pollution
ouais tu ne m'aimes pas problématique
majeure de santé parce qu'on prend pas
le temps de dire le dire on prend le
temps de manger on pollue la planète
royalement sous prétexte qu'on va avoir
une maison vendue par le rêve banquiers
les banques sont prêtes à nous prêter
parce qu'il faut sabbatique font de
l'argent il faut pas d'argent que nos
épargnes font de l'argent avec l'argent
qu'on va là qu'on va l'emporter
donc pour moi c'est un problème majeur
est plus le temps de faire deux
bulletins d'avoir du temps et si on veut
créative dans vis on veut être productif
il faut prendre le temps de rien faire
un moment donné faut que tu t'écrases
suis dit comment je ferais le monde
justaret regarder pousser l'herbe peu
c'est comme ça tu deviens créatif et ses
derniers miles de masse qui a toujours
vanté son 120 à 150 heures de travail
bon allez vite fait offrir un y
accrocher et cracher ses prêts sur la
vie oui honnêtement garde en suède il
vient d'avoir une étude de travailler 30
heures par semaine puis dans le centre
d'appels un manet mon comptable midi
françois des jeunes travaillistes
ravache maintenant je suis tout 40 45
heures par semaine françois m'a sorti
edistat les gens travaillent
trente ans par semaine thabo leurs
failles leurs horaires que je veux les
gens votent donner 30 heures par semaine
donc on est rendu que les les
les gentils moi je veux me craint qu'il
met moins de feuilles de thym d'en face
de mai à rome est imprimé regarde j'ai
fait quinze minutes d'où vous tenez un
employé comme ça que je vois réussi
écoute le gesppe ait voulu écouter je
fasse pas mais sur la ferme il est comme
ça dit sympathique mais le soudage et
fait 15 nouveaux thèmes aujourd'hui je
reprends paraître montant ou 30 à 50
heures dans ma banque
moi je fais je sais que c'est accompli
est ce que je suis satisfait de ton
travail
qu'est ce la réponse est oui là je m'en
foutais là je m'en fous même si la
semaine d'après tu travailles fort
est ce que le travail est fait si le
travail est fait
dati je te paie pour qu'un travail soit
fait je te paye pas pour des heures et
moi le principe de travailler pour des
heures ça devrait même plus exister non
plus et un travail à faire on s'attend à
ce qu'il soit fait puis sites exploitent
protégeant que moi je fais pas partie
des gens qui exploite les gens c'est le
travail je sais comme acte axa va
prendre mais c'est assez facilement
déraper par exemple si lon deadline
impossible à des gens pitt lors de leur
pays un certain montant qui équivaut
maintenant à 40 heures semaine mais que
c'est impossible c'est l'exploitation
waimes etienne manise fini par
comprendre le temps que ça doit pas pour
faire quelque chose
chuté je suis bon informatique je suis
bon dans les centres d'appels je connais
bien la ferme
c'est certain que se joignent montagne
de roches puis je te dis sauf surprise
déplacer puis placez un portes demain
matin je peux réalise si je dis comme et
axa votre penderie ne savons prendre
trois semaines de boycott je les fait la
semaine passée ça m'a pris deux 2 heures
il ya moyen d'aller trouver hors un
juste milieu
il cite à rediscuter discute avec tt
peut faire confiance au moins d'employés
ce n'est point d'employer personnes qui
travaillent pour moi
on travaille ensemble moi je roule à
faire puis mon rôle c'est soit des pdg
d'entreprises quand je conférencier
quand j'arrive sur staged tout est réglé
ok moi je serais allé faire mon affaire
devant mon speech de jeu écrit ce qu'il
faut que je parle je les ai toujours
fait tout seul
et elle m'a donné j'en ai tellement que
le jeu marilyn qui est ma blonde à
bouger en même temps bon travail
ensemble parce que je ne fournissait pas
tout simplement
j'arrivais soit mal organisés dans une
conférence mais maintenant quand
j'arrive tout est organisé d'avancé
juste lire ici le podcast c'est organisé
d'avenches ce à quoi m'attendre je sais
comme abyss et des niaiseries
mais ce pari fou avec un noeud papillon
quand j'arrive dans toutes les
conférences que je fais c'est fait c'est
la semaine pour assister les fans
conférence pour le parti conservateur
halifax 1 tout est organisé au quart de
tour mon speech est décrit murray 5-1
mon devoir c'est de nous
d'aller livrer une performance en avant
donc c'est pour moi c'est ça ne fait pas
son travail
je ne fais pas le mien comme il faut et
à la fin le produit parce que je pense
françois lambert se produit là il est
mal vendus lorsque je travaille sur la
ferme
simon a plié travail est trop bien sûr
la ferme je reprends le résultat les
récoltes ne seront pas le loup blanc
sera poussé comme il faut sur ramos trop
tard alors ce travail d'équipé juge je
travaille moi aussi je me sens que je me
suis retrouvé sur la ferme parce que ça
me reconnecte moins nettement j'embarque
que j'ai bulldozers grh et depuis deux
ans puis j'ai 5 1 à kaka bulldozers qui
mesure une pelle qui mesurent didier de
large
j'aime les roches qui ont toujours été
dans ma phase depuis 40 ans parce qu'on
a la ferme depuis toujours je pousse la
roche médias et wallace a fait 40 h
feuilletons de doigts je la pousse mois
m machu heureux une personne qui
comprend soit la personne qui était dans
une soirée c'est tapis rouge hier ben
c'est moi ça c'est moi c'est tapis rouge
c'est plus qu'une chose aussi c'est
qu'on parle et la sympathie que j'ai du
temps justement type est autant un gars
de la ville à la campagne comme si c'est
tantôt autant un gars de tapis rouge
d'un godet mais les jeunes reconnaissent
un moment donné j'ai appris avec le
temps les gens reconnaissent qu'une
seule image nous tenter d'identifier
occupation double pour un méchant boutin
regarde le poirier le poirier qui a fait
occupation double qui était le premier
millionnaire et mis dehors ok il se fait
encore parler d'occupation doit comme
c'était hier il y avait dix minutes dans
l'édition s'est fait 18 dans l'émission
il s'est même pas rendue ça y est elle
est flashé à part un passionné pour le
le le le film à quai il ya paul
occupation double pression due au fait
qu'il doive réfléchisse et millionnaire
il ya encore cette image la moelle et
les gens ont une image de moi point j'ai
beau avec les années
ce n'est pas moi ça le driver
les gens me voient de cette image large
et 10 il est maintenant de ne plus
essayer de la changer
moi je sais que la fin de semaine ça se
peut que je sois quelque part dans un
bulldozers work and johnson et mais je
suis parfaitement
heureux où je fais pas ça quand plaît
c'est une job qui est difficile qui
étoffent pis t'as pas beaucoup de
liberté quand tu fais ça se travaille et
se ferme tu n'as pas de liberté du
travail pointu tu lèves tu travailles tu
couches film et est heureux parce que tu
crées dessus surtout l'eau à kaboul je
déplace des montagnes là la montagne
pirello et puis le ra du labo un peu à
dieu je vais carrément le procédé et
puis s'il ya un plaisir fou d'être le
petit goût de 5 ha qui poussait son
petit côté je mets des oreilles parce
que seule la monaca précieux appui plus
pareil il ya un plaisir de créer un
plaisir de s'amuser tiges des poches
démolit pas le terrain pour démouler le
terrain pour venir la commande qu'on est
perçu dans dans l'est du public c'est
drôle toi parce que quand est présenté
dans une émission méthodes novatrices et
les millionnaires en dit assez débile
c'est assez bizarre même pas
l'entrepreneur si les millionnaires
comme si le nombre des rôles en tant que
la banque td finissait comme personne
sait s'il avait toujours été pied se bat
lui c'est lui et celui et celui miliana
ce qui est aussi j'ai répondu à dany
lévesque puis
richard martineau vous défendiez ralph
et puis tout le monde et françois
labelle entrepreneur millionnaire est ce
un qualificatif ou aussi débile thé mais
non tu devais commencer
ben on t'avait que louis bert
entrepreneurs pauvres s'est passé comme
le rêve américain de devenir
millionnaire comme un chiffre qu'on a
décidé que social gold
puis il à faire c'est que le monde le
savait même pas où j'allais à peine 1
j'en ai peut-être du vin j'avais
peut-être 200 millions à 500
c'est quoi ça qu'elle fillette c'est
flou c'est juste pour faire
spectaculaire auquel on a quelqu'un
parce que ce soit y est millionnaire
parce que le rêve du million
il fait rêver les gens vous faire
détester à lui me discréditer ce que tu
dis ouah c'est bête était millionnaire
pour le monde qui aspirent à 2008
c'est savent donc ce titre l'on me fait
rire un peu puis je suis pas le
politique parce que je pense peut-être
éventuellement faire reçu en politique
moi je veux bien peut-être plongée
probablement que les conservateurs du
canada mais c'est un moment donné va
falloir qu'ils me levais l'équipe fait
le succès beau que moi je peux y aller
mais moi j'ai un passé j'ai passé
facebook j'ai passé twitter j'ai passé
est passé quand même assez assez
controversée contre tu développes connu
les loose cannon à des partis politiques
le ça fait peur on n'en veut pas trop
ouais mais c'est moi j'ai jamais et sur
les personnes nommées l'usc tout faire
un pause par jour je pense aux facebook
wen jour quand on est bientôt là dans
des poses qui sème la controverse le ttt
de novak prend la parole et c'est sur la
facture dans ce parti politique ça fait
peur mais si jamais j'ai pas de dossier
criminel alors j'ai jamais insulté
aucune race
j'ai jamais insulté aucune religion j'ai
jamais insulter quelqu'un sur son
physique mais j'ai pris des prises de
position est pour moi j'ai aucun
problème puisque le jeu le disait
dernièrement
si je me lance en politique je j'ai
d'autres choses à faire qu'elle est
facilement passé sur facebook de toute
façon il était repris par le monde de
star line journal de montréal de l'efa
sable ce qui était qu'en ces temps les i
ce qui n'est contreversé et des jours de
prières dont je réponds la levée de
renvoi et mais c'est pour moi puis c'est
correct parce que je les assume
pleinement et quand je les grilles je le
suis mais si je l'avais pas assumer je
leur est facile rapidement pour dire que
le ça dérape je parlais avec sûr je veux
l'effacer
maintenant c'était cela je vais te faire
un boss tu te rends compte qu'il était
dans le chef dans le même temps l'ue
j'ai enlevé des poches parce qu'il prône
yapo déposants de bons mariages et c'est
bon ça je l'écris pluzz fait comme
j'écris ça puis à peine 5000 personnes
pilotée eu 400 milles sont nuls et non
je me suis rendu compte que ça
s'intéressent à ma personne et je
voulais pas que ça traîne ma base
danger aussi par un poste avec un petit
show pour justement un craint que le
monde où c'est oui mais si tu veux être
lu puis la fin on sectionne écrit
quelque chose c'est qu'on veut être lu -
donc si tu qui répond j'ai appris à
force d'écrire que ça prend un bon tir
bonne bonne fin ce qui est entre les
deux tu peux mettre main du blabla le
monde le lis beaucoup à part certaines
personnes mais la plupart du temps de
mon de voler c'est quand j'ai dit aux
gars de la construction change de job
même ok le de cette grappe anta partage
avec total a donné break pour sociologue
mathieu kg et avec mathieu bock-côté
équin un acte que je déteste
profondément choquées qui étaient but de
lui même qui n'écoute pas et denis
lévesque avait pas qu'on se batte parce
qu'on sait panier avant de rendre en
nombre mais c'est parce que la fin c'est
qu'ils d'anast qu ici il y avait écrit
un article sur moi dans le journal de
montréal puisse te plaît de faussetés
l'entrepreneur qui exploite les employés
j'ai jamais exploité personnes dont la
clé oui j'ai eu une entreprise qui
pouvaient pas payer des salaires élevés
des salaires entre 12 et 14 pièces de
l'armée le salaire ont payé tout le
temps deux pièces de plus que le salaire
minimum d'un bon c'est ça qu'on peut
faire c'est ce qu'ont à froges appuyons
les efforts c'est pau et à savez la
condition un bar avant de rentrer il
m'avait décrit comme un employeur
exploiteurs puis j'avais répondu être
pris comme un exemple pour tout ce qui
est autre chose dans le fond pourtant
ceci est quelque chose de laid ce n'est
déjà fait il ya profiter parce que tout
le monde aime des laïcs qui est le monde
écoute qui crée quelque chose qui
pendent blanc
d'accord mais roche est bien content
parce que tu es tu eu un impact non pas
sur un impact sur la société propose
l'impact sur les gens ont fait réfléchir
nécessairement l'elite plus que
l'approbation puis le fait que le monde
sait que te parler à quelqu'un oui je
sais que je peux faire ça parle à
quelqu'un sait ce dont tu sais que tu as
pas parler dans le vide donc été
pertinent peu importe ce que tu as été
site impose qu'ils peignent ce soit un
post facebook
instagram ou un twitter qui a marché
c'est que tu
2 du succès mais j'en ai eu énormément
pilote lui est venue faire ce qu'on
appelle du guinea pig et c'est ce que
j'ai pas aimé il est venu se servir
d'une pause que tout le monde par les
impôts venait se cherche et délègue
supplémentaire pour me planter que je
tenais mon employeur exploitants donc la
seconde et revend donc lui dit mon va
débattre dota 2 2 le coach ne vous juge
pas un imbécile j'en lis les livres
julie beaucoup la comprenait pas du mot
qui me disaient qu'ils voulaient et
l'éloignent meurent même et usain autre
mot que l'année les lunes et l'élite et
des employés oui je me souviens de rien
mais ce qui me glisse tamouls parce que
d ici sait pas quels mots pour te
mélanger parce que c'est sa manière de
s'exprimer
mika qui écrit dans un journal puis
pourquoi j'étais denis lévesque c'est
que il m'a planté et moi je m'en venais
pas débat je m'en fous royalement de
l'emploi qui veut habiter saint-jérôme
sai appartient pas qu'il faut le pollue
la planète
donc moi j'ai poteau électrique
parce que je suis le dos lectra m'énerve
simplement que moi manali montréal
québec est obligé d'arrêter en chemin ou
pensez à regarder même j'étais chargé à
20 en juin meeting temps cela j'arrête
en chemin mois pour moi l'auto
électrique est un passage vers autre
chose ça s'en vient il ya quelque chose
d'autre qui s'en vient des batteries
plus longue crise politique
quelque chose exactement mais son offre
en ce moment et pour moi c'est pas 100%
c'est pas 100%
donc moi j'ai un diesel un camion diesel
je mets du diesel deux dates les 1000 km
je mets de l'urée donc chapeau lui
presque peau jassaint paix serait pas à
l'aise donc lui par les bleus débarquent
de so2 du déplacement
l'étalement urbain moi pas que ça pollue
ça me regarde pas moins que cet abbé
saint-jérôme puisqu'elle chantier de
construction et au centre-ville de
montréal
c'est ton problème c'est l'épaule mais
pour l'auteur le trailer pour le fait
que j'allais passer par un débat de
société sur un support sociologue en
homme d'affaires puis toi si tu
travailles pour moi puis d'habitat à
saint sauveur puis ma job je te donne à
montréal si ton problème tu vois ce pot
de miel
moi je suis trop faire une job des
places 3 s'attendent maintenant que je
choisirai pas parce que je me dis c'est
pas de bon sens il va démissionner après
après trois mois et je pense que lui
c'est à guy martin peut dire mais il ya
des gens pour qui cette job losses c'est
pas celle là c'est pas de job day fait
défaut des forces et de faire des
affaires que soit pas optimale mais que
ouais mais ça c'est une mentalité qu'il
faut changer parce que c'est pas vrai
qu'on est obligé de travailler pour
quelqu'un on est en période de plein
emploi et je pense que si t'es pas
d'opportunité de changer de job une
envie c'est peut-être parce que t'as pas
pris un moment donné les bons choix de
carrière dans ta vie aussi certains ont
choisi un métier qui est appelé à
disparaître si tu choisis arrêté l'école
au matin bémol si tu choisis de
d'arrêter l'école après le secondaire st
ça se peut tu trouves pas beaucoup de
portes pour le futur et ça se peut que
tu peux me dire oui mais tu as une
famille pauvre vieux objets d'alice le
marché du travail
je viens d'une famille extrêmement pour
vraiment me dit toi tu t'en vas l'école
ok un impair qui te quand même encouragé
la danse
ce n'est pas négociable des gens qui ont
les parents alcooliques qui ont des
parents qui viennent de milieux clément
difficile c'est dur de les blâmer pour
pour réussir dans vie dénoncé ce mais je
regarde comme un coq hommes
marchisio tu as écrit claude en centre
ville il vient d'une famille puis il
écrit un livre ses bons mots qui pour
faire ce couple il vient d'une famille
son frère et dans rue d'antin de
gauthier s'est faite par où était de 2-2
de famille d'accueil à famille d'accueil
la famille d'accueil lui étaient
destinés pour terminer dans rue
alcoolique - piatti moi ça m'intéresse
porsche va me prendre mais il ya
toujours un moment donné on peut
toujours blâmer la société met toujours
un moment donné que tu dis moi là je me
branche belge en partie d'accord avec ce
que tu dis parce que oui
dans un sens je pense que d'autres
responsables individuellement des choix
qu'on fait il faut l'être parce qu'ils
sont blondes toujours les autres pour ce
qui nous arrive mais on n'avance pas
c'est pis ça fait pas de nous quelqu'un
qui avance dans la vie sauve que
quinconque un conte prend du recul qu'on
regarde la société
et mettons à vol d'oiseau un peu plus
pillon la pauvreté ces statistiques
c'est souvent héréditaire des problèmes
de même c'est pas facile à régler
si tu le dis pas pour juste blanc mais
l'individu ou s'il ya des besoins
urgents
c'est sûr que here est ce qu'on vit dans
une société qui est raciste et quand on
peut se le cacher là puisse faire
accroire départ à montréal on était
habitué on est multiethnique
ok ça de montréal lyon de la musique ok
faut se dire les vraies affaires là lyon
de la mesure même à montréal
moi j'ai vu que j'ai eu ma compagnie fox
qui existent encore manier comme
développeur j'avais comme huit ou neuf
béninois super intelligente personnes de
les embaucher les gens sont racistes et
des noix ils embauchent peu au hockey
tout simplement moi je m'en fous de
couleurs mafuta race et du bon on va
savoir il faudra travailler ensemble si
c'est sa part fait d'étranges argent
n'ait eu d'étranges en parfait au que
ces points importants je regarde pas qui
demande moi je regarde plus large en cas
de pré sexe jorgan un talent et c'est ce
que faut s'habituer mais je viens d'une
famille que ces valeurs là est
importante mais c'est certain que les
gens n'ont pas le choix des red neck
américains ont adhéré aux consorts dans
nos rêves
ce sens d'une note du redneck là donc
c'est l'ail et je comprends que ça paie
difficile dépendamment moche mais blain
en santé tout bois tout en se gardant
ville effectivement il y en a d'autres
qui disent vega moi je vois m - les
chances c'est certain que si on arrête
l'école après le secondaire scène des
chances d'avoir un très bon d'emplois
éventuellement ribes bien rémunérés tu
m'as prêchant de tombes sont plus fins
sont plus faibles
ça fait penser que c'est impossible mais
reste que tu est un peu limité mais
rebonds la question c'est qui en blanc
mont blanc entre l'individu et hop tu
avais juste à côté des études où on
blâme l'espèce de des systèmes qui
encourage pas assez les gens pour ceux d
ailleurs personne à blâmer mais les
divisions de pauvres deborah blomet la
société non plus choquant est situé le
sens c'est dans l'es6 et sa bonne avant
tout les sens mais c'est certain que
vient pas blâmer la société à un moment
donné
tu peux toujours retournent aux études
si tu veux tu peux toujours aller
apprendre à lire site us lawe asus avait
pas tu peux toujours il ya un moment
donné d'attaqués dans ta vie que tu peux
décider moi je vais prendre des cours le
soir y en a qui le font les mères de
famille monoparentale qui prennent des
cours à l'université pendant qu'ils sont
en train d'élever des enfants qu'il n'a
jamais rencontré un paquet côté aussi
trop d'enfants maison que j'ai pas le
temps fasse pas tout tous seuls
megan j'ai craint pas sur les assistés
sociaux c'est un des premiers cafés
thérapie saunier j'habite encore à
donner les briques et une de mes amies
qui fut mon ami aujourd'hui avec team
parce que moi j'avais des câbles des
assistés sociaux
c'est un aide de dernier recours il ya
en aucun cas nos besoins mais lorsque
c'est de père en fils à petit fils ya un
problème c'est pas normal et elle aime
dit à me répondu à 10 monomère et de
soul bs à fumer des cigarettes qu'elle
avait trois enfants élevés avait pas le
temps d'aller travailler est en santé
pourquoi convoi eut donné c'est elle qui
décide c'est moment donné de faire trois
quatre ans ferme pour avoir des revenus
en année photo yd garde j'arrive pas
peut-être que je m'arrête à brens enfin
là c'est beau avoir une famille mais ça
prend de l'argent à élever une famille
il faut qu'ils passent à manier car
peut-être que là ça va être trop
difficile peut-être que je vous retourne
aux études mais conçoit comme société
son exemple
désolé j'ai jamais été d'accord avec
elle c'est pas un bon exemple c'est ce
qu'on veut pas dans une société c'est
des gens qui se mettent ils viennent et
qui font des enfants répétition
prendrait plus de bien être social
ça ne fait pas une société en santé
c'était une mauvaise exemple moi je
disais quand et en santé puis de façon
avant l'hommage que corriger les règles
depuis tête en santé c'est soit que tu
vois tu dis soit que tu me demande
sérieusement que tu cherches un job
sinon ton bien être votre coupé de
moitié et c'est tant mieux parce que mon
neveu peau une d'aider des désastres
sociaux de génération en génération
ces lots pour un aide de dernier recours
c'est là parce que des capacités
limitées
c'est là parce que
depuis le chômage tu es mal pris tu as
fait une dépression on veut un filet
social on veut pas vraiment le
capharnaüm mon veut pas des gens qui
s'assoit là dessus puis travailler au
noir parce que c'est la réalité aussi
dans les campagnes et le beaucoup sont
ceux bien-être social assez d embaucher
un possible besoin de travailler au noir
y en a à tous les niveaux de la société
aussi oui mais a cédé à bout j'ai
dépassé des impôts qui fait 10 millions
il plus dommageable que celui qui paie
pas ses impôts qui fait aimer par année
mais non non pas d'accord il ya personne
qui fait 10 millions que paie pas ses
impôts
j'écoutais aujourd'hui québec solidaire
on veut imposer plus j'ai un moment
donné qu' il ya une responsabilité
j'utilise pas plus la route que toi
j'utilise propulsé école que toi c'est
quelque chose je vais utiliser moins
parce que je vais probablement aller
dans une école privée
j'utilise pour le système de santé parce
que je n'ai pas le goût d'attendre donc
un moment donné est-ce que je dois payer
comme un débile des impôts à finir pour
couvrir la société est devenue une
société socialiste
moi ce que je sache le canada pcc québec
n'est pas comme ça oui mais on pense que
les capitalistes fous que tu sois un peu
balisé quand même sinon ça creed des
trop grandes écoles d injuste mais d'ici
six mois comme homme d'affaires je
réussis à voir une entreprise hyper
entame libère rentable pas parce que je
souhaite mais un bruit parce que je peux
pas les exploiter mais après ils vont
aller travailler ailleurs sont exploités
faux gel des salaires compétitifs mais
une entreprise c'est pas juste des
employés si tu siro ce savoir faire que
de développer une façon de faire
marketing que ton compétiteurs ne fait
pas une économie d'échelle que
l'entrepreneur capable de faire si je
capable de tout faire ce puits bâtir une
entreprise qui fait énormément de
profits est-ce que j'exploite quelqu'un
non est-ce que j'étais plus brillé à
quelqu'un oui et pour sow
forgeard donne le paquet à la société
était où la société le temps que j'ai
pris des risques en lançant la fin j'ai
pas d'abandonner
et lorsqu'on vend l'entreprise qui on
donne
25% de la femme dans son entreprise ou
gouvernement il était poli tout le temps
moi j'ai jamais une subvention de la
ville
mais il ya là des subventions pour les
pme par exemple mais pourquoi l'école
pourquoi parce que si tu demande une
subvention
tu demandes une supervision de l'état
moi la dernière chose que je dois faire
après mao lancer en affaires la
marijuana mais qui vont me demander mais
c'est aux financières tout bouge appuyé
sur comment sa note a plus droit de
dépenser maintenant la culture ne se
lance en affaires brava la liberté n'est
pas mais qui aurait pour 10000 pièces de
subventions j'en ai jamais voulu y en a
qui en veulent il y en a qui font des
plans d'affaires là-dessus taxi tt aux
taxis en était un coupe uefa moi je
blâme pas l'ex homme d'affaires d'avoir
été chercher des subventions affectées
aux taxis le gouvernement lui a donné et
un programme qui est l'eau qu'ils aient
eu accès il y en a profité pour
l'ancienne entreprise c'était son modèle
d'affaires
on peut pas le blâmer moi c'est pas mon
modèle la fin parce que ça n'implique
que le public demande les cons ça
implique que le gouvernement a demandé
compal impressionnants ces entreprises
pour qui est même pas mal de chez vous
donc pour moi je me tiens loin des
subventions de plis crédit suppôts
bouger dans la voir j'en prends peau est
d'ailleurs ma philosophie avec c'est
toujours été de dire si ton entreprise a
besoin de subventions pour devenir
rentable tu es toujours à merci d'un
gouvernement à l'autre donc pas de futur
cette entreprise là parce que si tu as
besoin de te rejoins dans la marne au
caire a bien dit moi c'est fini les
subventions main tendue aux taxis c'est
sous les poteaux start et donné un coup
mais après ça si on veut non sur les
positions massives des entreprises puis
des individus il ya une limite à ne pas
franchir
on doit payer plus 100% d'accord on est
ce qu'on doit payer sur plus c'est assez
iea paca d'endroits regarde en france
ils l'ont fait et ont surtaxés
entreprises ont dit les entreprises qui
font de l'argent on voit surtaxé qu'est
ce que les entreprises de paris ont fait
sont à l'essai salle à londres parce que
londres
la cité de l'ombre est un paradis fiscal
donc c'est facile c'est font pas si la
zone euro bingo là le break 700 vient
donc le lol
l'angleterre va sortir de la zone euro
ils s'envolent au liechtenstein les gens
sont mobiles les entreprises sont
mobiles mahdaoui de plus un bureau
d'affaires c'est que c'est populaire
parler de l'évasion fiscale je parle pas
de la fraude fiscale et la fraude
fiscales pour l'évasion la planification
fiscale
on veut tous passés les entreprises qui
utilisent les paradis fiscaux c'est
populaire dans par les tripolitains va
en parler
la réalité c'est que c'est un problème
qui ne se réglera jamais jamais jamais
jamais parce que toujours un étau
quelque part qui vont être prête à
accepter une entreprise l'état du
delaware charge d'euros pour ça 51% à 55
ou 60 % des entreprises aux états unis
sont enregistrés dans l'état du delaware
bon viennent entendre le génie bouchard
qui s'est étalée obama ses yeux rien
d'illégal là dedans il s'installe en
déplace tous que les impôts sont les
moins les moins élevés comme petites
entreprises on ne pas axer je peux pas
déplacé mais un de mes petites
entreprises moins dans des paradis
fiscal ça marche pas c'est les grosses
grosses grosses entreprises qui font ça
parce que une façon de tuer un paradis
fiscal qui très très simple qui
complexent en même temps c'est moi je
peux bien avoir une compagnie si à
montréal et jeunes compagnies bidons
dans un paradis fiscal
la compagnie dont elle c'est très simple
à détient tous les brevets que j'ai que
j'ai fait de détenir dans l'entreprise
que j'ai besoin et par la magie de la
communication de facturations
la compagnie qui est dans un paradis
fiscal ma charge un gros prix pour
l'utilisation de mon brevet bingo je
viens de transférer des fonds dans une
magnifique halle de façon parfaitement
légale partout mais ce qu'ils font pour
le monde ce qui est fort cher c'est que
pierrick valomet 10,91 peu mon brevet de
charges trop cher pis pour ça qu'il est
juste les grosses entreprises parce que
toujours le grenelle 1 voté non ce
brevet leur est dû à être l'oeil été
houleux
le recherchent donc les vraies
entreprises vont déplacer des employés
dans dix ans ces places là pour faire la
vraie recherche donc la recherche et
développement que tout ce qui le nerf
d'une entreprise en santé se fait
déplacer vers les paradis fiscaux
parce que l'utilisation comme il le
faisait auparavant de déplacer de forme
le brevet ailleurs mais c'est quand même
en jeu si moral rien d'illégal la dalle
tactile is bond mode de facturation
mais bon c'est ce que l'air d'en parler
ou là c'est juste l'osm pour la classe
moyenne si souvent vouloir faire
accroire qu'on vient de québec tai chi
nombre de photos tantôt la radio le
monde appelait pour chialer de l'artiste
si on suivait et mêlant subventions
façon album offert cible phare ce moi ça
me fait lever le boisseau les bras parce
que 20 et le pias le c'est des peanuts
le trident dans le spectre du
gouvernement anti d'argent qui ce fait
qu'ils ont fait à croire aux gens la
classe moyenne que ceux ci paient
beaucoup d'impôts psi-20 coutach
spéciaux péter service qui voudraient sa
cause des gens en dessous d'eux les
artistes les gens sur le bien être
social qui en réalité justement et
désignant ce montant comme ceux qui
sortent de la province près du pays
seoul la vraie justice ceux qui
profitent situ l'artiste sur soi-même et
pias où c'est l'autre qui me sont des
millions des paradis fiscaux
mais les uns le problème d'utilisation
des paradis fiscaux parce que je peux
parler de fraude la fraude carrément
sursis après l'utilisation des paradis
fiscaux et vous être toujours quelque
chose de difficile pour ce que je n'ai
de vous expliquer ce silence il est si
facile à faire pour une baisse les bras
devant aux idéaux mais sans faute qui ce
n'est pas en surtaxant les entreprises
qu'on va régler le problème s'étend les
soutes accent il leur faire comprendre
regardez on vous donne des impôts c'est
de l'éducation point final qu'il faut
faire la différence
faut éduquer les hommes d'affaires que
qu'est ce qu'on fait avec cet argent
l'eau mais lorsqu'on lui demande tu fais
10 millions de profits entendant lève 66
millions qui sent bien des postes au
gouvernement on regarde l'état des
routes on regarde le tour des écoles on
regarde les taux de
c'est actuelle actuellement votre écoute
mon argent sera pas bonne place le lien
problème c'est certain il y en a pas de
service vote et malléable votre aval
hôpital tata 48 heures pas normal
oui oui mais ça arrange l'autre sens de
circulation parce que les routes ont
tout démoli nos sociétés actuellement
elle est malade parce que on a mal fait
l'utilisation des fonds pendant
plusieurs années il on est pris aux
frais des services médiocres avec un
prix très élevé est ce pour ça que les
gens en ont pour leur argent pièce est
de maximiser les impôts puis si
seulement les grandes entreprises c'est
pas les petites entreprises qui font
soucier les grimaces entreprises mais
c'est quoi c'est quoi le bon modèle
c'est les états unis s'est fixé le nom
le bon modèle faut faire attention aux
états unis parce qu'il est débile
profond qu'il gère le pays mais les
états unis ont des choses de bon il ya
des choses de moins bon la norvège qui
te pays socialistes sont des choses
excellent aussi il ya des choses moins
bons aussi
donc faut prendre le meilleur de tous
mais pour moi surtaxer les entreprises
n'est pas la solution est ce que la
solution dans le fond ce que ce que tu
entends dire c'est que la solution ce
serait de mieux expliquer pourquoi c'est
important que les entreprises restent
ici il faut avoir une taxation qui est
concurrentiel point de vue mondial
la première chose qu'il faut c'est
compte concurrentiel avec notre voisin
qu'ils les états unis ils viennent de
diminuer le taux d'imposition des
entreprises
on vient d augmenter c'est et reculer
parce qu'il ya une crise bill morneau a
essayé ça que ça propos s'est donc hissé
non il semble augmenter le fardeau
fiscal des entreprises alors que lui en
bolivie est ce la réalité c'est quand tu
baises leur fardeau fiscal des
entreprises très peu d'entrepreneurs
vont s'en mettre plus d'impôt recherche
d'un autre bateau ce qu'on veut c'est
créer de la richesse
on veut grandir constamment on va
l'acquérir et quelqu'un d'autre on va
quérir un concurrent un autre pays
on est des dominants et des dominés d'un
vrai entrepreneur est un dominant qui
veut contre qui veut constamment grandit
donc cet argent leur supplémentaires
vont créer de l'emploi sur le moteur
tout simplement oui va peut-être avoir
un dividende plus généreux à fin de
l'année
c'est ben correct y'a pas de problème il
sait si c'est oui vont avoir le dessus
mais le gros de l'argent vont être
surtout réinvesti donc faveur d'une
fiscalité concurrentielle appartement
mais n'a pas parlé de l'artiste puis
ramené un bon point
moi comme cultivateurs maintenant depuis
quelques années j'ai une obligation de
performance
si je veux avoir l'assurance
stabilisation parce que pour faire de
l'agriculture au québec puis fait de la
grille tout comme on fait c'est pour ça
que je fais du j'ai commencé à faire du
houblon fait des choses différentes
parce que si tu bois fait que du maïs et
du soya
je ne peux pas vivre sans l'assurance
stabilisation mais avant les
agriculteurs à planter du maïs balance
si tu mets de l'engrais tout en occupe
de ton chant comme il faut l'assurance
stabilisation de payer pure mais
bêtement par rapport à ce que de semer
les aux intérêts plus ça marche pas
comme ça
maintenant vous soit le plus performant
dans ta région les plus performants va
voir ça de ce but d'assurance
stabilisation puis si tout était moins
performante sur un mois 0,2 donc comme
agriculteur maintenant je dois performer
si je vais avoir le droit ne sera
stabilisation sinon c'est mon voisin
coteaux à côté de moi produite deux fois
plus que moi parce qu'à engraisser ses
chers parce que ce mot au bon moment je
répète subventions c5
maintenant les artistes quelle est leur
obligation de vendre que celui que vient
d'avoir 20 milles puis on parle de ta
des crédits des poulets halal et la
télévision parce que des fois si je
mange un effet des projets de télévision
autres que les dragons qu'on regardait
faire un autre show télé qui regardaient
en cavale m comme ça parce qu'on va
avoir le droit crédit au crédit d'impôt
pas subventions mais si chaud que je
fais les cinq personnes qui l'écoutent
piste un flop total il y en a des flop
total
melita pas longtemps non plus ouais mais
on le doit à la subvention philippines
l'agriculteur maintenant nuit il n'y a
pas le droit donc même l'aller les
allèles le latisse devra vaudois de
subventions mais avec une obligation
aussi de performer au final chaude à lui
raté les prix des cotes d'écouté of no
et vidéo que les gens vont aller voir
sur youtube of new la performance qui va
permettre que cet argent lui vaut faire
d'autre argent parce que c'est une règle
investis dans la culture je suis pour ça
mais la culture sans obligation sarah
shourd est très raide gardien je pense
que tout le monde d'accord avec ça mais
je pense que tout n'est pas que
l'artiste qui crèvera être entendu votre
écoute et personne qui fait ce juste
pour ça
pour le végal nomiya j'ai tourné un
vidéo la vidéo clip pour un groupe qui
s'appelle sébastien org dehors de ses
bases
il ya un première chanson qui était vu
des millions de fois sur youtube
donc là ils ont eu le droit je veux que
ça marche comme ça quand même un peu
puisque l'oeil ont été reconnus il y
aura le droit à une subvention pour
faire un vidéo donc là ils ont eu plus
de budget fait m'embaucher gt2 ça
s'appelle le magasin de pièces
je sais pas ce que ça va donner comme
résultat mais ils y ont performé puis
maintenant on doit une subvention c'est
correct ça soit comme ça c'est le super
forme peau l'europe une subvention
propose une vidéo
donc y'a pu payer déjà de lui des eaux
pour être capable de faire quelque chose
de ce qu'est le tgb d'accord sauf que
c'est juste que leurs organes encore la
culture avec une seule lunette qui la
lunette de l'économie c'est de l'argent
mais la culture c'est un genre de luxe
qu'on se paye finalement en tant que
société mais pour créer une espèce de
lien social que tout le monde a des
références culturelles communes qui fait
qu'on partage quelque chose puis aussi
la culture tout et les gens qui chialent
se rend pas compte qu'ils en consomment
tous le monde écoute ses missions la
télévision qui selon moi je comprends a
été de fait de la télévision de vue des
caméras à l'épaule
pete est quand même dans un grand show
mai
t'as pas besoin de grand chose faire un
show de qualité là avec les caméras de
voie radio canada les caméras sont high
tech
ça coûte une fortune les gens pour faire
un choix télévision de radio canada a
besoin de huit fois plus de staff que de
faire un show à l'ailé je regarde
l'image mon pays je vois la même chose
lorsque je regarde le show mais non
parce que tu enlèves raid au canada puis
will certains certaines personnes
critiques qui sont qui sont biaisés ou
quoi que ce soit qui sont teintées mais
c'est quand même probablement dans
l'information celle qui la plus
objective qu'on peut avoir la bonne idée
de mettre la hache dans radio canada est
ce que radio-canada doit avoir tous les
milliards qu'on leur donne leur
demanderez des buildings et et de radio
canada
pur produit des shows qui ont pas les
meilleures cotes d'écouté non plus c'est
il faut regarder moi je suis toujours
dans une optique de revoir constamment
ce qu'ont fait les du mot dans une
entreprise si tu te re nouvelle peau tu
vas être dépassée et l'enac société
d'aujourd'hui
aussitôt qu'on parle de ce s que ce pôle
est encore nécessaire on parle
d'austérité c'est ce que ça crie ça ce
soir lors il sait ce qu'est ce à dire
sur moi j'étais allé dans les bureaux de
radio can puis effectivement dans
n'importe quel jeu phare de métier si tu
te renouvelle peur tu fini par mourir
problème c'est que il ya beaucoup de
médias traditionnels traditionnelle en
fait qu'ils continuent à avoir les mêmes
du qui avait vu le 20 et 30 ans dit
qu'ils sont plus actuelles du tout outil
fait qu'effectivement de revoir la
performance mais plus fréquemment 18
mois je sais pas si dix mois c'est la
bonne tels que notre homme à faire c'est
leur métier au pas des tas de services
qu'on offre aux citoyens puis pour moi
ça doit être revue constamment sarkozy
doivent revoir au complet mais d'oser de
tout refaire est-ce que j'en donne aux
clients pour son argent
radio canada ont un manteau mais
produire une émission de culture elle
qui vont et écouter le samedi après-midi
par 150 personnes
est ce que ça vaut la peine de réserver
un temps d'antenne pour ça ou ça devrait
aller sur le web
il faut se revoir un moment est-ce que
c'est ce que le modèle de rendre
complètement changer justement avec la
venue du web qu'il faut en faire passer
les enfants et à moi chez moi j'ai cinq
télévision lmp
je veux avoir quelque chose je me
promène à son laptop dents mais j'écoute
la télévision sur mon laptop otv je sais
même pas pourquoi j'en est allé partout
j'ai fait le même but mais bon c'était
comme ça va puis a déménagé bas que ça
prenne télévision j'ai mis des divisions
dans charme de mégots je pense qu'ils y
ont jamais paisible le own dessus depuis
deux ans donc on ne consomme plus puis
j'ai quand même 50 et honneur et je fait
déjà plus partie de cette général
moi je suis plus un millénaire mais
emilie et nous mais je sais ce que se
jouait déjà avec des jeunes seraient des
jeunes je m'appelle t que je trouve que
de jeunes parce que j'étais entouré de
jeunes mais enfin vous et que je fais
mon âge mais mais on consomme plus du
tout les médias comme on les consomme et
ça se décide sur un iphone même pas
l'ipad pour les jeunes et le laptop on
est on est là dessus donc faut revoir
constamment c'est pas en offrant plus de
choix la télévision c'est d'offrir plus
sur les plates formes qui sont
différentes
je dis moi j'écoute rien sur deux mais
j'ai boycotté netflix le changerai
d'écouté jack ryan sur amazon prime je
me promène entre en dessous quand j'ai
le goût d'écouter puis des fois je peux
passer deux mois ça rien écouté je vais
aller voir des bouts d'os de prix sur
youtube si c'est bon t'es toujours
briller le jour mon frère ce prêt de
chizé à ma blonde et c'était au mois de
mme d'avril les moines mais il ya des
moustiques à fait né sais que j'ai
besoin d'avoir un vidéo de moi avec le
bulldozers qui sort le tracteur qui
brille je passe mon texte et ça c'est un
autre faux confirme enfin que mes filles
parce qu'il faut revoir notre société on
peut avoir une meilleure société sans
mettre la hache et pour moi c'est juste
de dire à personne car ce que tu fais
maintenant plus personne en a besoin je
te mets pas porte mal fait faire autre
chose
c'est pas les gens toujours pas à mon
père de ma job c'est pas ça qu'il faut
regarder
qu'est-ce qu'on peut offrir les gens
consomment pareil on consomme du contenu
encore plus qu'avant ils m'ont consomme
différemment et c'est ça qu'il faut
aller chercher pas seulement sur
radio-canada dans notre société
point de tout l'argent ou ce que ya des
subventions d'elle une subvention pour
un show télé pour moi m'a tant donné un
petit peu là puis mon talent elle est
beaucoup plus c'était des codes des
côtes après six personnes qui
l'écoutaient a manqué son coup tu me
servais savons même si c'était pas son
objectif donc des buts de dépasser pour
t'assurer que soit ta deuxième thon
deuxième paiement
il est poli d'accord à partir ce que tu
dis c'est juste ce que je dis c'est que
la de regarder la culture avec seulement
la halle à lunettes de ski et ça
rapporte versus commence à coup tu sais
comment ça rapporte
on passe à côté d'un truc un peu c'est
sarah qui parce que si j'aime les grands
ballets canadiens
c'est mon droit à moi je mente pas que
la société aime les grands ballets
canadiens parce que moi j'ai décidé que
j'aimais ça faut se poser comme question
aussi est ce que la société décide ce
qu'on vaut aimer et et aux balles puis
soutenu par une riche dense néerlandaise
qui donne 20 millions par année là où
donc
mais ce qu est est ce que si elle n'est
pas l'or est ce que c'est à nous autres
comme ce site de pompéi 20 millions par
année là dedans je sais pas je n'ai pas
la réponse mais pour moi il ya pas 4 go
disque
je ne sais qu'il ya d'autres bienfaits
qui vante qui sont pas aussi faciles à
voir les retombées de ces exemples les
rayonnements qui les artistes québécois
ont international sape et aérostier
samecki sabine québec san mames sentir
du monde ici c'est sa place au soleil à
sion eu vraiment des subventions
auraient besoin de subventions les lions
une maudite bonne idée on dit des
cirques avec des animaux sa parure pu
nous on va faire des cirques avec un
choc la musique
bingo il ya fait différemment n'est
celle qui existe est partout il ya fait
une recette différente
les autres sections tout moore qui est
maintenant la cde copie le 5 juin
je pense pas qu'un artiste qui le succès
qui cueille qui est pas entrepreneur le
je pense que je pense que tout cela
semble que ça fait partie de la game
c'est juste ça mais ceux qui ont eu du
succès c'est justement des entrepreneurs
de la région qui sont partis de rien
puis en partie un rêve puis ôtez
visionnant arsenal fond pour réussir une
entreprise c'est pas de visionnaires
comme on voit ce porto le fait en avant
de monter c'est pas bon 2 1 si cette
fois est faux comme 2-1 la taxe bâti son
entreprise que tu des neiges que tu te
fasses la night forme d'un nouveau pic
en même temps que les gens ont besoin de
ça puis ont besoin du renouveau puisque
le soleil darde exactement à l'état pour
ce qu'on a dit non les animaux l'entrée
des fous de se faire fouetter dans un
siècle un éléphant qui s'assoit ça nous
attire peau on va aller les voir on va
faire des affaires en infraction trip là
dessus mais c'est pour ça qu'on veut on
va voir un tel un artiste reçoit une
chinoise qui balade 80 assiette avec ses
mains c'est ça qu'on veut voir où
quelqu'un qui se garroche avec une roue
les gens ont depuis avec la musique
entraînante et c'est ça que les gens se
situer juste que le discours de lui vit
il vit ce brut gouvernement piste et aux
subventions de ce ca existe paulette
recommencer cette subvention c'est pas
des têtes une subvention c'est le
problème du gouvernement se pose le
problème du groupe
si une subvention qui existent les
gonzesses quoi on allait appliquer pour
ça qu'on lui donne 6 puis son problème à
lui c'était le gouvernement c'est quoi
les systèmes quoi les qualificatifs pour
qu'ils l'aient est ce que est ce que
c'était correct wii u
comme un bonbon parce que cette période
électorale on l'a su donner pour acheter
des votes où on l'a acheté parce que ont
ils donné si le conseil des arts du
canada où s'est incliné cd jury datent
souvent des gens du milieu je pense que
c'est des gens qui vont vous faire c'est
pour ça que je fais beaucoup soirée on
met vite ont jeté mes billets je paie
600 mille pièces par billet pour amasser
des fonds pour les grands bals et pour
amasser des fonds pour les enfants comme
en face mais n'engage pas les horizons
charlevoix fête du vélo pour amasser des
fonds qu'ils ont remboursés 100000 donc
il ya des organismes comme ça quand on
paye on pas subventions ces gens là ils
font des soirées ils font des tournois
de golf pour g en cdd puis moi j'ai
décidé puisque jeunes talents sportifs
puis que je veux que les jeunes bougent
moi c'est mes causes - on vient pour me
demander de l'argent pour une soirée de
la culture
car après une scène de ma part même
manoir la leaf à 100 km des côtes de
charlevoix souffraient comme un bon que
la journée pour redonner cette ambiance
à quelqu'un et l'eau moi ça fait mon
affaire je donne je m'entraîne puis je
donne un exemple aux jeunes les gammes
j'ai beau succès ce pôle mais je suis
encore en forme puis non ce morceau je
prête à redonner en faisant du sport
mais ça c'est mon choix moi la culture
est toujours une problématique et c'est
toujours quelque chose que tout le monde
les pauvres de mon épaule lorsqu'on n'a
pas lorsqu'on vient dans les poches en
ville les gens commencent à être moins
moins fort en fin mais c'est que c'est
peu mais c'est parce que 166 la
consommer
c'est peu c'est pas gratuit la culture
faut quelques la face ça demande des
moyens seulement personnel sont en
prévente au barça reste propre moi j'ai
décidé que je nageais le matin bah c'est
ça jugé capa personnes avec ça mais je
manque pas personne ne voulait me donner
de l'argent parce que je vois l'énergie
le matin donc je donnerai pas de
l'argent quelqu'un parce qu'il faut
maintenir les effectifs n'ont jamais
atteint prophète personne d'autre qu'à
toi pas du tout parce que le fait que je
nage de ma tâche est en forme et je
risque de retarder mon temps où ce que
je vais aller remplir les hôpitaux
vous savez je vais si on veut régler
notre problème depuis
d'engorgement c'est pas mettre plus
d'argent dans le système de santé pour
les continuer à régler des enfants des
personnes malades faut les prendre très
jeunes leur donner des habitudes leur
faire comprendre de ce ca fais partie se
crée l'école il ya pas une heure de
sport par semaine
you know sport par jour ok puis à
l'école on va leur réapprendre à
utiliser un budget qu'est ce qu'on fait
dans la vie on cuisine bon j'ai de
l'argent
tout le monde a tout les jours on pense
à mon fils tu l'argent morgado que
j'étais assez d'argent que je fasse un
transfert on fait ça tous les jours
qu'est ce qu'on apprend à l'école 02
dessous on n'apprend pas cuisiner on
arrive après le cégep ont dû aux boys au
kef où je me fasse à manger qu'est-ce
qui rendent la maison c'est grave de
nuuk d'eramet c'est la première chose
que les jeunes vont manger parce que
coûte 33 cents et ramène donc on va
manger ça parce qu'ils veulent
économiser et c'est pour ça qu'on doit
apprendre on doit apprendre à fait
qu'avancer paperphone cuisine et
retrouver des moments en famille moi des
fois je fasse mes gosses il ne peut pas
qu'est ce qu'on mange ce qu'on mange
je veux aller manger quand vous avez des
fêtes le monde ensemble quand je ne fais
pas que les jo mais quand j'ai décidé de
bouder ben je veux manger dans mon coin
je leur prépare rien jusqu'à ce que le
goût de manger et de cendres on va faire
quelque chose ensemble
donc il faut notre société peut être
réglé puis on peut être un leader dans
le monde en faisant les choses
différemment comme un entrepreneur doit
faire les choses différemment
je pense que en inculquant des saines
habitudes de vie en inculquant que garde
souhaité par forme à l'envi faut que tu
sois en forme point final nom du peuple
puisse non seulement ça marche bien fait
attention à 6
attention ton pote on diabète on est
dans une société qui est malade se
connait maladie
on prend du sucre moins que j'ai fais de
l'exercice sur cinq a jamais su le faire
avant je consommais 150 grammes de sucre
par jour je me promenais toujours comme
ça ok fatigué à dormir fasse cadeau
remet ses 33 g gundam
de notre avis de notre physique qu'on a
c'est 33 grammes de sucre par jour une
canette de cox et 39 grammes de sol le
double thème bastille mais enfin on
apprenait le carré vert le genre en plus
dans maison puis il tout le monde
prendre lobo surpris personne et s'ouvre
les veines donc et je pense que c'est un
metteur en inculquant d'une nouvelle
chose qu'on vous réglez ça vous coûter
moins cher a faim on ne finira jamais de
mettre de l'argent dans le système de
santé la façon que c'est fait nos écoles
c'est la même chose c'est pas mettant
plus de profs le budget de l'éducation
ont explosé en trois fois plus de
jacques travaillent dans les bureaux que
notre prof sur le prochain bon ça n'a
aucun bon sens car aucun brin vieillot
les services aux élèves sont 5 qui
regarde un prof travail et n'a aucun
sens j'ai une amie qui m'a fait j'ai une
temps qu'il prend sa retraite de
l'enseignement primaire
j'ai une amie qui commence à enseigner
en assam imprimeur puis les doigts même
constaté ça ils ont juste un moyen les
plus en plus de cas problèmes dans
l'éclosion doute aidé à acheter du
trouble attachement ainsi un certain
temps dans ma classe qui ont pu de piper
d'accueil ont pu darty qui ça fait que
c'est pas de l'enseignement de la
discipline mais si on regarde les écoles
on demande lorsqu'on a vu son marché du
travail aujourd'hui comme axa se passe
on est dans un bureau vers une table de
poule on les salles de jeu on l'a des
horaires flexibles tout le monde
s'arrange comme ils veulent
avec la capsule genou il ya des work qui
font fureur parce que c'est des
primaires on se présente quand on veut
pourquoi que ses entrepôts les
entreprises sont devenues comme ça c'est
pas parce que l on va être cool pas ça
ça répond à un besoin de société un
besoin des libertés parce que nos
employés ce qu'ils veulent la première
chose de le salaire et la troisième
reconnaissance liberté salle à notre
connaissance c'est simple fait un bon
travail
je veille bravo ou en gestation entre
faisceaux mind coach veut jamais je me
serais même pas été capable de fait sa
une à
merci beaucoup toi là tu viens de tuer
de façon à ce qu'on dit et tu viens de
me donner du gave de pau trois semaines
lâche pas obligé d'aller te revoir était
heureux jeunes et à donner une
reconnaissance absolue
tu as fait quelque chose que je suis
impressionné deuxième chose qu'on veut
c'est de la liberté
ce qu'on donne à nos enfants à l'école
et ont pas de liberté pas de
reconnaissance
tu réussis pound pénalise sur ce que tu
ne réussis pas de ne pas de bonbons si
tu réussi quelque chose parce que c'est
pas sûr on est dans un mode répressif tu
réussis possède une correction sur ie6
pas ça tu veux te faut venir le soir en
récupération et en même temps ne pas
liberté sont assis dans un bureau
six heures par jour ce que j'écris
aujourd'hui 600 par jour
on se lève constamment prévu sur notre
facebook pourrait prendre un café on
jase un peu on demande à nos gens vous
allez vous comporter d'une façon que
vous allez jamais vous comportez
éventuellement dans votre vie mais dont
on va vous demander de vous comporter
dans un état où vous cite même pas
capable de vous comporter comme ce port
d'envaux le voit que nos gars corps
fonctionne pas je vais une école à
drummondville saint bernard et au total
vais les murs il ya des places de
travail tu peux tu veux travailler fort
et sain et sauf
ce travail est écrasé son souffle tu
veux te revient à l'équipe c'est très
bien dit qu au lieu d'avoir douze profs
et ont trois profs pour gérer la même
chose qu'avant les élèves font leurs
horaires si ça fonctionne au bois est en
fait comme les entreprises et c'est ça
qu'on doit faire on doit revoir
constamment notre façon saine écoles
privées dont qui ont pu faire réfléchir
à ça mais le problème aussi c'est que
les profs c1 et il s'est probablement le
maillon le plus important dans la
société ce lucky tran qui forment les
jeunes qui forment les futurs adultes de
demain 26 qui transmettent le savoir
qu'ils sont payés des salaires à ses
presque là il s'agit au départ c'est le
problème c'est le départ qu'ils sont mal
payés mais il n'y a jamais une paye qui
va être assez bonne mais on va augmenter
le salaire des profs définitivement
commence à 26000 apprécié quand 80 90
minutes correctes
au début c était payée à peine 26 milles
ça doit rien changer dans les conditions
de travail à clé d'abord j'ai changé sur
la contrebande
c'est ce que font courir 26000
t'encourage pas grand monde mais si la
job était vraiment le fun
puis travailler dans un environnement
qu'ils font le salaire ne serait pas une
problème c'est pas mon talent salaire à
45 milles qu'ils doivent jouer lui qui
lui qui vont la médecine parce que c'est
qu'il va faire tel salaire si
l'enseignement c'est une profession qui
étaient respectés qui était vu à sa
juste valeur comme la médecine ça
attirait certainement des gens c'est ça
je pense apprend 22-14 rentrée à
l'université en enseignements c'est
comme n'importe qui et 22 de 14
je pense que les standards devraient
être plus élevés les salaires plus
élevés que ce fait que les profs si
c'est l'élite de la société ccpo comme
les latins mais on les voit pas comme
sur vie avance et je faisais moi quand
j'étais jeune les profs étaient les
riches les villages bouger le village
les plus belles maisons que les profs
qu'ils avaient fini ce temps l'autre
qu'est ce que ça fait ici il manque de
modèles masculins
c'est sûr que c'est un monde de filles
les professeurs il manque des films cima
mais pourquoi que ça tire pas les ans
c'est pas une question de salaire c'est
autre chose que ceux-ci l'encadrement
c'est l'afrique c'est tellement dur
les jeunes y la plupart veulent même
plus prendre des tâches complète parce
que c'est trop dur il tombe en brisgau
dieu parce que de ressources et ont peu
d'argent et on peut dire trop de
problèmes dans leurs classes sont juste
pas capable à m'en donne un cours
magistral et des enfants qui ne sont pas
faits qui ne sont pas regarde comment ça
marche en ce moment notre société nos
sociétés on est une société aéro plein
air miles 1 point - les lignes ce mot
chez métro la carte de pointage et
provigo avec un point on voyage nous
pourrons regarde tous nos points je lé
fais moi aussi j'étais un point où ce
que je peux aller
donc on a accumulé des points
secondaires des crédits on accumule des
points entre les supermarchés qu'on
était en échange d'avoir quelque chose
en retour donc à chaque fois qu'on qu'on
achète on a un bon retour
puis nos jeunes sont et sont élevés là
dedans c'est la génération un mal ils
ont quelque chose en retour de chaque
comportement qu'ils font est donc c'est
des récompenses qu'on leur donne
constamment la donne toujours la carotte
à l'école c'est quoi ce comble pas le
contraire il n'a pas de carotte il ya
pas des deux de destatis
ap
formés parce qu'on est paulo dans le
domaine sens de l'appel on a réglé le
problème
au lieu de pénaliser les gens on l'est
on leur donne des bonbons s'ils font
leur travail comme il faut donc on donne
on donne aux gens des 10 dès maintenant
les gens ce qu'ils veulent si pu être
pénalisés s'ils font quelque chose de de
pauw correct ils veulent quelque chose
en retour d'un comportement normal et
c'est que nos jeunes arrivent à l'école
puisse attendre sont pas habitués
d'écouter quelqu'un parce que on n'est
plus là
le cours magistral n'existe plus il faut
revoir ce au complet le fait d'un autre
façon et access d'autre part faire ses
points d'honneur des salaires supérieurs
que ça va régler le problème des
salaires supérieure moi j'ai déjà gagné
deux cent cinquante mille jugé que la
capote
je sais pas si mon salaire je suis pas
de fonds d'ici à dix qu'à la party fun
et pollock à la partie reconnaissance et
paulo quand on bosse on reconnaît pas de
barbe et de l'argent il y en a jamais
assez que jamais assez d'argent pour
être vu mais c'est ça je pense que le ce
que je dise que les savants je pense que
c'est une des solution parmi d'autres
mais juste de reconnaître le travail de
ces personnes le qui de l'ivoire de
standing qui va avec ceux qui comme
quand même être ça la société ce que je
disais oui mais parce que ans a fait le
tour il en est on à dépasser notre
intérêt mutuel
merci beaucoup qui était de 2 ans non
habituelle mais le merci beaucoup d'être
venus et mais ça me fait plaisir
bascou qui est une discussion
extrêmement diversifié agissante des
enjeux j'imagine que tu parles dans ton
prochain livre effectifs sont en octobre
oui on va lâcher ce avec ne-yo libye
aussi merci beaucoup merci
[Musique]